l'ordre du jour appelle les questions au
gouvernement je vous rappelle les règles
dérogatoires d'organisation de nos
séances de questions en raison de la
crise sanitaire ne sont présents qu'en
nombre limité des ministres et un ce
début 10 par groupe les questions ayant
le même thème sont regroupés chaque
question faisant l'objet d'une réponse
spécifique le nombre de questions et
réduits en revanche les temps de parole
sont les temps usuels du minutes par
question et autant par raiponce réplique
ou contre eux réplique éventuelles
comprises afin de limiter au maximum les
effectifs des personnels présents je
vous rappelle aussi que la liste des
orateurs dont avait eu connaissance
n'est pas affichés sur les écrans durant
la séance enfin les règles sanitaires
habituel continuent à s'appliquer
nettoyage des micros en cours de séance
les orateurs sont invités à ne pas poser
les mains sur les micro et à utiliser
des micros différents respect des
distances entre les participants entrée
sortie échelonnée
nous commençons notre séance par des
questions portant sur la crise du que
vides de 19 en général notamment le
thème de la santé
la parole était madame brigitte kuster
pour le groupe l'est républicain
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le premier ministre
et je la pose au nom de l'ensemble de
mes collègues du groupe l'est
républicain
elle est d'ordre plus général si vous le
permettez monsieur le premier ministre
le président de la république a défini
un cas c'était indispensable pour donner
aux français un horizon de faim de
confinement et leur montrer que leurs
efforts leur vigilance et leur esprit de
responsabilité commence à payer
mais au préalable un éclairage sur le
choix de la date du 11 mai serait le
bienvenu par ailleurs je voudrais ici
vous dire combien ou constatons avec
plaisir que le président a repris à son
compte plusieurs mesures que nous
réclamions depuis de longues semaines
avec mes collègues les républicains oui
nous devons faire preuve de plus
d'humanité pour toutes les personnes en
fin de vie en
permettant à minima de dire adieu à
leurs proches
oui nous devons aller beaucoup plus loin
sur le soutien aux entreprises et aux
filières les plus touchés par la crise
en annulant purement et simplement
l'ensemble de leurs charges pendant la
période de confinement oui il nous faut
en finir avec les failles les ratés les
lenteurs de votre gouvernement sur la
distribution des masses et la
généralisation des dépistages néanmoins
des zones d'ombré subsistent et j'y
reviendrai dans mes prochaines questions
mais tout d'abord un sujet d'inquiétude
sur lequel nous attendons des réponses
précises
la réouverture annoncée des crèches
écoles collèges et lycées
bien qu'elle soit nécessaire inquiète
légitimement de nombreux parents alors
que les enfants sont souvent des
vecteurs asymptomatiques du virus quels
arguments scientifiques justifie ces
réouvertures sur l'ensemble du
territoire
pourquoi ouvrir au premier les écoles
que vous aviez pourtant fermé en premier
et êtes vous prêts monsieur le premier
ministre
enfin organiser un vrai débat sur ce
sujet devant la représentation nationale
je vous remercie
merci chers collègues la parole est à
monsieur le premier ministre monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
députés madame la députée posé beaucoup
de questions dans cette dans cette
première question je vais essayer d'y
répondre d'abord un mot pour dire que la
décision qui a été prise et assumée de
procéder au confinement l'a été vous
vous en souvenez sans doute pour
garantir que le nombre de malades
présentant des cas sévères ne soient pas
nombreux au point de saturer totalement
la capacité des établissements
hospitaliers français à accueillir des
malades en situation de réalisation dans
des services de soins intensifs
c'était la raison confinement freiner la
circulation du virus pour faire en sorte
que notre système hospitalier ne soient
pas des bordels
il n'a pas été débordée il a été soumis
à une tension extrême
il a tenu grâce à l'incroyable
engagement de ce qu'ils font vivre grâce
à des trésors d'imagination de ceux qui
ont su augmenter les capacités d'accueil
dans l'ensemble du système hospitalier
nous sommes vous le savez passé à dix
mille lits de réanimation
quant à ceux qui ont eu la capacité
d'organiser des transferts de patients
entre régions ou vers l'étranger de
façon là encore à désaturer à à
permettre d'accueillir toujours dans des
conditions acceptables ce qui se
présentait avec des cas sévères à
l'hôpital c'est l'objectif du
confinement et c nous commençons à le
constater et il faut le dire avec une
immense prudence c'est c'est ce que nous
voyons commencé à produire des résultats
avec un nombre d'admissions qui ralentit
avec un nombre de malades en réanimation
qui diminue lentement sûrement pour
l'instant mais avec là encore je le dis
beaucoup de prudence car au fond ce
résultat ne tient que parce que le
confinement est respectée une fois qu on
a confiné pour cela il est bien naturel
que la décision de des confiné qu'il
faudra prendre dont le président l'un
public indiqué qu'elle commencerait à
intervenir à partir du 11 mai est un
lien avec les raisons du confinement
autrement dit nous pensons que vers le
11 mai nous aurons su diminuer le nombre
de malades en réanimation
nous aurons su permettre à l'hôpital de
reprendre une forme de capacités face à
au stress inwi face à allah l'intensité
de la première vague à laquelle il a dû
faire face hier le président de la
république a fixé des principes la
sécurité sanitaire continuité de la vie
de la nation des objectifs le
déconfinement progressif à partir du 11
mai
et il appartient au gouvernement de
mettre en place les instruments les
méthodes la doctrine d'emploi un
coordination nécessaires pour faire en
sorte que ces objectifs
rappelé par le président de république
soit atteint c'est ce à quoi nous nous
employons nous nous employons avec
l'ensemble des membres du gouvernement
avec l'ensemble de l'administration mais
c'est ce à quoi nous allons nous
employer en collaboration bien entendu
avec les organisations syndicales et
patronales qui sont directement
intéressés par cette question du
déconfinement progressif avec les
collectivités territoriales qui sont
directement intéressés par cette
question d'une déco finement progressif
et puis le président la république hier
a également formulé des exclusions
principe les objectifs puis d exclusion
il a indiqué d'ores et déjà qu'il
n'était pas envisageable de réouvrir les
restaurants et les cafés l'hôtellerie
restauration café à l'horizon du 11 mai
il a d'ores et déjà indiqué que festival
ne pourrait probablement pas se tenir
d'ici la fin du mois de juillet parce
que évidemment des événements qui qui
rassemble avec une grande densité ne
sont pas envisageables
nous allons donc devoir mettre en oeuvre
les politiques publiques de façon à
tenir les objectifs en respectant les
principes qui ont été rappelés par les
prisons de la république et pouvoir
commencer ce déconfinement voilà
pourquoi la date du 11 mai a été évoquée
mon objectif c'est de faire en sorte que
ceux des confirmands progressif puisse
se passer dans les meilleures conditions
miss de l'éducation nationale a eu
l'occasion de dire que ce déconfinement
progressif il se traduirait peut-être
peut-être par une forme adaptée de
réouverture des écoles
je ne veux sur ce point rien annoncé de
définitif puisque nous sommes en train
de travailler mais je n'exclus pas assez
vrai qu' on puisse envisager à partir du
11 mai que les écoles fonctionnent de
façon un peu différente de celle
de la façon dont elle fonctionne
normalement puisque par définition nous
ne sommes pas dans une période normale
et chacun peut l'apprécier mais pour
pouvoir dire cela précisément et je
comprends l'impatience vous la formule
est d'une certaine façon et une
l'ensemble de nos concitoyens la partage
nous devons étudier dans le détail avec
l'ensemble des acteurs concernés
la meilleure façon d'organiser une
logistique complexe de protéger nos
concitoyens de garantir leur sécurité
sanitaire se sont véritablement les
principes qui nous guide et sa demande
en effet du travail de préparation alors
l'impatience est telle qu'on demande de
répondre question par question au
débotté à tel ou tel point qui semble le
plus intéressant immédiatement la vérité
c'est que le président de l'unfp public
il l'a dit hier clairement a demandé au
gouvernement de préparer un plan complet
de sortie un plan d'ensemble
j'aurai l'occasion de le présenter quand
il sera prêt largement avant la date du
11 mai mais il doit être travaillé il
doit être aussi travaillé en
consultation avec beaucoup d'acteurs
pour être véritablement à la hauteur des
enjeux jour merci merci monsieur le
premier ministre la parole est à
monsieur dominique potier pour le groupe
socialiste et apparentés merci monsieur
le président ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le premier ministre a fixé une
date c'est un peut conjurer la dame
nation d'une fin du monde ou d'un monde
sans fin on voit bien toute la force que
cela peut représenter mais en même temps
en annonçant cette date même avec
prudence comme l'a fait le président de
la république nous posons des questions
autant que nous apportons de réponse
aujourd'hui une des questions majeures
qui est posée aujourd'hui c'est celle de
notre responsabilité est ce que cette
date est trop précoce pour certains
secteurs notamment dans l'économie et
les encore tardivel un coût public
économique important pour d'autres
occuper la dignité humaine la santé
ce que nous partageons tous ici sur les
rangs elle pourrait être trop précoce
alors être responsable c'est le
responsable de ce qui est fragile comme
disait paul ricoeur être enceinte
responsables ceux qui sont fragiles et
d'autres groupes politiques a été un de
ceux qui a été le plus en pointe sur la
question de ces enfants pour qui la
visent terre ferme et de ses aînés dans
la solitude est confronté à la fin
dernière
et notre groupe est également soucieux
de ce qui est fragile dans ce rapport de
la vérité de la parole publique
alors pour lever toute ambiguïté ce que
vous pouvez nous dire monsieur le
premier ministre si nous avons adopté
cette doctrine autour du 11 mai malgré
l'absence de tests parce que nous avons
la persuader ne sommes persuadés que
étant asymptomatiques n'avons pas besoin
d'être testé c'est une question
extrêmement importante
on a longtemps dit qu'on pouvait être un
symptomatique est porteur vecteurs de la
maladie
et puis nous avons rassemblé autour des
communautés éducatives pas seulement les
enseignants étaient dit 'tiens les atsem
toute la communauté éducative des
enfants des adolescents
le 11 mai est ce qu'il n'ya pas une
contradiction fondamentale en la matière
sur cette question des tests nous
n'aimerions pas que se répète
l'idée et se répondent cette rumeur
comme quoi les doctrines se font en
fonction des carences et qu'elle
s'adapte au principe de réalité puisque
à la recherche de la vérité
pour nous être transparent sur ce sujet
être clair est-ce que nous disposons des
moyens de tester la population française
pour que le 11 mai soit en rendez vous
avec la santé pour tous et une santé
durable merci merci chers collègues la
parole est à monsieur olivier véran
ministre des solidarités et de la santé
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
député dominique potier merci pour votre
question qui me permet d'intervenir sur
la place particulière du dépistage au
moment d'envisager la levée du
confinement
nous avons eu plusieurs fois l'occasion
de débattre de discuter des enjeux de
ces tests je voudrais que les choses
soient parfaitement identifié il ya en
réalité deux grandes catégories de test
il ya le test qui vous permet de savoir
au moment où fait un prélèvement avec un
ego visionnage et ensuite un diagnostic
sur plateforme technologique qu'on
appelle une pcr qui vous permet de
savoir si oui ou non vous êtes au moment
où vous réalise le test porteurs du
virus et donc potentiellement malades
que vous soyez symptomatique ou non est
liée à un test qu'on appelle la
sérologie qui a pour but à partir d'une
analyse de sang de déterminer si vous
avez en vous des anticorps contre le
virus ce qui veut dire qu'alors vous est
immunisé et donc que vous avez été
exposé convenablement au virus
suffisamment comptablement pour
développer des anticorps que vous ayez
été symptomatique ou non l'enjeu il est
double il est encore plus fort au moment
on lève le confinement pour pouvoir
répondre
à des français qui s'interrogeraient
légitimement pour savoir si oui ou non
ils ont développé une immunité certains
d'entre eux n'ont pas été testés par pcr
alors qu'ils avaient des symptômes et en
même temps d'être capables à chaque fois
qu'ils la suspicion que quelqu'un
présente les symptômes de la maladie ou
une personne contact rapproché
exactement ce que nous avons fait le
député au stade 1 et au stade 2 d'être
capable de faire immédiatement un test
est d'isoler toute personne pouvant
transmettre la maladie
ces deux équipements de tests répondre à
deux logiques qui sont différentes mais
que nous poursuivons semaine après
semaine
l'augmentation de nos capacités pcr avec
l'installation de 20 plateformes haut
débit l'achat de millions de tests en
france et à l'étranger et puis
l'équipement sérologie qui viennent
juste d'arriver sur le marché mondial
qui n'existait pas encore il ya quelques
jours et qui nous permettent désormais
de disposer de moyens plus fiables de
diagnostic
quant à l'immunité des personnes encore
une fois ces deux tests distincts mais
parallèle nous sommes en train de
renforcer nos capacités pour pouvoir en
faire massivement le moment venu pour
pouvoir répondre à la demande encore une
fois légitime des français merci
monsieur le ministre la parole et au
monsieur jean christophe lagarde
président du groupe u10 agir et
indépendant merci monsieur le président
monsieur le premier ministre je suis un
peu moins inquiet qu'hier soir puisque
le discours du président de la
république donner le sentiment d'un
impératif le 11 mai alors que depuis ce
matin j'entends les membres du
gouvernement dira un objectif dans les
conditions sanitaires doivent évidemment
être rempli et en premier lieu pour ce
qui concerne la réouverture des écoles
12 4 millions d'élèves et tout le
personnel de l'état naturellement mais
aussi des collectivités locales qui sont
nécessaires pour les accueillir et donc
beaucoup de questions se posent
puisqu'elles ont été les premières
fermes et elles seraient les premières
ouvertes si cet été les premières fermes
et sans doute est elle cède sur lesquels
nous avions le plus d'inquiétude sera
obligatoire est ce que les élèves seront
accueillis par groupe
est ce que les régions les moins
touchées vont être concernés mais l'est
de la france et l'île de france
peut-être moins est ce qu'il est
nécessaire j'ai compris que vous aviez
besoin de travailler monsieur le prémice
donc j'apporte un certain nombre de
questionnements naturellement pour ce
travail et nous souhaitons pouvoir y
participer peut-être sous la forme que
vous avez adopté dans les échanges entre
les groupes parlementaires et le
gouvernement est il indispensable de
rouvrir des crèches et les maternelles
ou les gestes barrières sont impossibles
à respecter et à faire respecter qui
prendra la décision d'ouverture les
maires ou les présidents de conseils
départementaux et régionaux où l'état
parce que ça te pose un problème de
responsabilité pénale naturellement les
cantines scolaires devront elles être
assurée et puis surtout il y aura t-il à
la date du 11 mai ou plus tard si on
devait reporter cette date des masques
pour les enfants pour les enseignants du
gel en quantité suffisante bref des
mesures de protection qui garantissent
que en allant à l'école l'enfant qui
bien souvent peut être vecteur mais il
n'est pas touché par la maladie ne
ramène pas cette maladie à la maison
brice camp alors de faire repartir
l'explosion une proposition d'ailleurs
ne serait-il pas plus sage de se
concentrer sur les classes d'examen les
classes à orientation qui pourrait pas
être accueillis dans des établissements
dans des conditions sanitaires plus
satisfaisante bref nous avons du travail
à faire et nous souhaitons pouvoir le
faire ensemble sur le premier ministre
merci chers collègues la parole est à
mme haché le premier ministre monsieur
le président mesdames et messieurs
monsieur le président la gare
l'importance qui s'attache la
réouverture des écoles n'échappe à
personne ici c'est d'abord parce que
l'école c'est évidemment le lieu de
l'apprentissage
depuis la fermeture des écoles
une immense majorité des enfants de
notre pays grâce au remarquable travail
des enseignants a pu poursuivre ce
parcours de d'enseignement d'acquisition
de connaissances de travail il faut en
remercier tous ceux qui l'ont rendu
possible les enseignants
au premier chef mais vous savez comme
moi et vous savez même probablement
mieux que d'autres monsieur le président
la garde compte tenu de votre
circonscription d'élection que dans un
certain nombre de cas liés parfois des
inégalités sociales parfois des
inégalités territoriales parfois des
inégalités familiales parfois au cumul
de ces trois d'une égalité là qu'un
certain nombre d'enfants de notre pays
se retrouve dans la période que nous
connaissons dans une situation
d'éloignement vis-à-vis du parcours
éducatif vis-à-vis l'acquisition de
connaissances vis-à-vis de la réflexion
beaucoup plus loin que d'autres et pour
cela le jeu devrait pas dire ce terme de
coûts l'impact l'impact du confinement
est à la fois très élevée et
probablement très durable et c'est bien
la raison pour laquelle nous devons
faire extrêmement attention à ce que
collectivement nous soyons capables de
ramener vers le chemin de l'école comme
l'a dit le président de la république le
plus grand nombre de nos enfants il ya
donc un impératif qui qui réel bien
entendu il ne peut pas se faire au prix
de la santé bien entendu il doit être
mis en balance si j'ose dire quand je
dis mis en balance et conjuguer plus
exactement avec la nécessité de
préserver la santé de nos concitoyens de
garantir le respect de règles sanitaires
qui qui sont qui sont évidemment
décisives et auquel nous pensons à
chaque instant et c'est ça le travail
qui nous attend et je sais que certains
imaginent parfois les commentateurs que
tout devrait être au fond arrêté comme
sortant sinon de la cuisse c'est vous
qui l'avez dit au moins toute armée du
lui la tête
deux jeunes c'est qui la vérité c'est
que si nous voulons mettre en oeuvre
d'une façon intelligente et efficace
cette nécessité du retour à l'école nous
devons le faire avec les maires vous
avez raison nous devons faire avec les
professeurs nous devons faire avec
l'ensemble de ceux qui participent à la
vie scolaire et nous devons le faire de
façon ingénieuse en garantissant les
moyens de protection en vérifiant si
nous pouvons réellement et dans quel
endroit adapté l'organisation de la
journée ou adapter les lieux à des
règles qui permettrait dans de
meilleures conditions à la fois de
pouvoir faire court et en même temps
garantir la sécurité sanitaire
or tout ça exige à la fois une politique
générale sur laquelle nous allons
travailler des adaptations locales
laquelle nous devons travailler avec les
préfets les sous-préfets avec les maires
avec l'ensemble de l'administration de
l'éducation nationale et bien entendu
avec les professeurs ça prend du temps
je sais que nous vivons dans un monde où
on aimerait que tout fonctionne au clic
paf ont appuyé puis ça se passe bon ben
c'est pas comme ça que ça se passe et on
le sait bien et donc nous sommes en
train de travailler nous le ferons en
bonne intelligence avec les présidents
de groupes parlementaires comme je me
suis engagé avec une discussion qui je
crois vous pouvez en témoigner monsieur
le président la garde qui régulière et
qui est je vous en remercie je vais le
redire d'ailleurs puisque comme vous
êtes privé de micro je voudrais bien que
ce soit sincère merci
et c'est et c'est comme cela que nous
allons réussir à avancer et à trouver
les bonnes solutions en ayant toujours
et systématiquement en tête les
impératifs de sécurité sanitaire de
préservation de la santé de nos
concitoyens mais en ayant aussi en tête
l'impératif de continuité de la vie de
la nation continuité de la vie de la
nation
ça n'est pas rien c'est la capacité que
nous avons à préserver les générations
futures
d'un impact trop durable est trop
important une déscolarisation d'une
distanciation vis-à-vis de l'école nous
devons donc concilier ces deux
impératifs en bonne intelligence et une
façon efficace
ce n'est pas facile ça je vous le
concède
ça n'est pas facile et c'est ce que nous
pouvons faire merci monsieur le premier
ministre
la parole est à monsieur françois bon
pour le groupe e liberté territo merci
cependant monsieur promise j'entends et
je partage tout à fait votre avis à la
fois l'obligation d'organiser les choses
mais il ya maintenant un peu urgence
puisque le 11 mai c'est dans un peu plus
de trois semaines et donc d'ici là il
faut évidemment que nous nous
organisions sur les territoires et il
faut que l'on sache comment ça je prends
des hommes très précis le lundi 11 mai
si certaines écoles réouvert ce que nous
souhaitons tous les parents d'élèves
vont accompagner les enfants dans leur
école et donc ses parents d'élèves
devront eux-mêmes avoir un masque pour
se protéger puisqu'ils vont ensuite allé
devant l'école collectivement à la même
heure comme ça se fait régulièrement le
matin et le soir lorsqu'il récupère
collectivement et donc ils seront en
groupe devant l'école donc toutes ces
questions là elles sont bien trop
pratique effectivement il faut que nous
soyons capables d'apporter une réponse
assez rapide idem peut lire le premier
le prénom un public l'annoncé que
certaines entreprises
certains commerces pourraient réouvrir
le 11 mai et donc il faut aussi que l'on
sache comment s'est employé ces
commerçants pourront rouvrir leur
commerce et dans quelle mesure mais je
voudrais aussi interpellé le ministre de
la santé sur les tests jeux ministre
suite on a entendu il ya le prénom le
public parler des tests qui seront faits
pour les français qui ont des symptômes
il ne parlait donc pas des tests
sérologiques et donc je pense qu'il faut
apporter une précision
vous l'avez dit mais je pense que ça
doit être précisée parce que on ne peut
pas imaginer 2d confiné nos concitoyens
s'il n'y a pas là deux batteries des
textes à la fois les tests pour
constater s'il ya des malades et des
tests sérologiques pour voir s'ils l'ont
été il ne prend en ayant parlé que d'un
seul test nous sommes un peu inquiets
nous avons besoin d'eux des précisions
et enfin je voudrais juste dire que je
vais moi hier pour le coup un seul petit
regret dans le discours du prénom
république au delà les primes des tests
c'est qu'il a beaucoup parlé des maires
et des collectivités locales mais je
pense qu'il faut ne jamais oublier les
maires les présidents des conseils
départementaux les présidents des
conseils régionaux qui ont été je crois
exemplaire durance
période et dont nous aurons besoin pour
vaincre dans le combat qui est le nôtre
merci chers collègues la parole à
monsieur olivier ferrand ministre des
solidarités et de la santé monsieur le
député françois pupponi j'ai répondu
tout à l'heure effectivement sur la
question de tests le président la
république a raison d'insister sur la
nécessité que toute personne
symptomatique puisse être testé par des
crs vers le test où on fait un
prélèvement découvrions qu'on envoie aux
laboratoires
parce qu'il faut savoir si quelqu'un a
présenté des symptômes et qu'il est à la
fois potentiellement malade lui-même
mais qui peut contaminer d'autres
personnes de manière à ce que toute
personne testée positive soit isolé
c'est ce que nous avons fait souvenez
vous encore une fois au stade ce n'est
pas quelque chose de nouveau
ce qui est nouveau en revanche c'est que
nous aurons l'existence parce que la
recherche a avancé de tests sérologiques
qui permettront d'apporter un autre type
de réponse mais vous avez raison de le
souligner vous même si quelques uns des
symptômes ce n'est pas un test
sérologique dont il a besoin c'est bien
un test pour savoir si la lutte sur lui
le virus et qu'il était actuellement
contagieux donc vraiment les choses
s'organisent se met en place
aucun pays est en avance par rapport à
nous tout simplement parce que en
matière de tests sérologiques pour ne
citer que cet exemple il n'en existait
nulle part il en existe de façon
expérimentale parfois des entreprises
ont pu se hâter à l'étranger de
commercialiser des tests dont certains
pays acheteurs ont pu hélas constater
que la spécificité de ces tests où la
sensibilité de ces tests où ces deux
critères indispensables n'était pas au
rendez vous vous avez raison également
souligné le rôle majeur des élus locaux
des mères on en parle des présidentes
département et j'ai plus qu'à mon tour
une occasion de saluer notamment
l'action du président de l'association
des départements de france dominique
bussereau qui nous accompagnent par
exemple dans la stratégie de tests
systématiques en ehpad dès qu'il ya une
suspicion de cas c'est normal de nous
appuyer sur les collectivités
de la même façon qu'il était normal
d'aider les régions qui avaient fait des
commandes par exemple de masques ou
d'autre matériel de protection à
l'étranger notamment en chine et qui
était en grande difficulté pour ramener
ce matériel
chaque fois que nous avons été sollicité
les services de la diplomatie le service
des transports mon collègue jean
bapstiste djebbari pourrez vous en
parler à chaque fois le gouvernement a
été au rendez vous pour accompagner ces
les élus locaux dans leurs démarches
d'apporter sur le territoire national du
matériel je dirais que l'unité nationale
c'est aussi évidemment à ce stade qu'on
la retrouve merci monsieur le ministre
la parole est à monsieur avec phil
corbières pour le groupe de la france
insoumise merci président monsieur le
prémice hier soir le président de la
république s'est donc adressé à tous les
français pour leur annoncer qu'à partir
du 11 mai le gouvernement allait
organiser la réouverture des écoles car
je le cite
il s'agira de permettre au plus grand
nombre de retourner travailler
la date du 11 mai apparaît donc comme le
début de la fin du confinement actuelle
si je dois dire une stratégie à risque
et hasardeuse car dès lors beaucoup de
questions de remarques se pose d'abord
d'où vient cette date
quel est l'avis du conseil scientifique
il n'a même pas été évoquée hier soir
par le président de la république
pourquoi aucun débat contradictoire sur
la pertinence de cette échéance et le
dispositif sanitaire planifiée qui
l'accompagnerait n'a même pas été
organisées ici à l'assemblée nationale
cet ultra présidentialisme la parole je
dois avouer ne correspond pas selon moi
à la période actuelle et la crise
politique aussi que nous rencontrons
mais surtout quels outils allez vous
utiliser pour éviter la propagation
demain massive d'une deuxième épidémie
dans les risques seraient importants
pourquoi n'allez-vous pas généraliser
les tests sérologiques dont vous ne
parlez pour tous à commencer par ceux
qui sont invités à reprendre leur
activité professionnelle pourquoi
limiter les tests à ceux qui présentent
des symptômes nous savons tous que l'on
peut être porteur du virus de façon
asymptomatique
pourquoi faire courir des risques aux
enseignants aux personnels des écoles y
compris aux enfants en étant incapable
de dire dans quelles conditions
sanitaires cet accueil scolaire pour
avoir lieu sans test image qui va
remettre ses enfants à l'école si ce
n'est ceux qui sont contraints à des
raisons professionnelles
pourquoi faire courir des risques à tous
les salariés actuellement 30% des
salariés continuent à l'ailé sur leur
lieu de travail et vous n'assurez pas ne
sont pas capables les lélés pas qu'on
l'ait des employés ne sont pas capables
d'assurer à tous une protection
satisfaisante et d'ailleurs nous n'avez
toujours pas défini quels étaient les
secteurs essentiels
bref on a le sentiment que vous répondez
à une injonction de la part du ménage
qui nous dit business d'abord alors que
l'aspiration des français c'est santé
d'abord je dois vous l'avouer
vous avez fait beaucoup d'erreurs depuis
le début de cette crise beaucoup de vos
déclarations gouvernementales ont été
erronée ont été contredites par la suite
pouvez-vous quel que soit vous en dire
plus à date du 11 mai car sachez qu'il
ya dans ce pays une grande méfiance vous
avec des cette décision est un sentiment
que ce que vous recherchez c'est d'abord
affaire m'avertir au travail beaucoup tu
ne penses plus rien dans des conditions
ne sont pas encore réunies la parole est
à monsieur de ministre des solidarités
et de la santé monsieur le député
alexis corbière je ne doute pas une
seconde que si le président de la
république n'avait pas posé une date
hier vous n'auriez pas manqué de l'avoir
félicité pour ne pas avoir déterminé
cette date et que vous n'auriez pas
poser une question pendante à dire quand
allez vous reprendre français et leur
donner des perspectives mais puisque
vous m'interrogez en mettant en question
le choix de cette date monsieur
corbières sachez qu'en aucun cas il ne
s'agit de suivre une logique purement
économique
contrairement à ce que laisse entendre
le raccourci que vous faites entre deux
segments de phrases qui ont été
prononcés par le président de la
république parce que je les bien écouter
le président la république hier et il a
commencé par parler des inégalités
insupportables les inégalités sociales
du corps bien je suis sûr que vous êtes
sensible à cet argument
il a aussi parlé du rôle fondamental de
l'école pour la formation
l'apprentissage des enfants pour leur
permettre d'évoluer en société je suis
sûr que vous êtes sensible à cet
argument monsieur corbières et puis là
parlait aussi la nécessité de pouvoir
rendre à des personnes dans la société
la possibilité de retrouver une
perspective
oui de développement social économique
et demain culturel il a également dit et
premier ministre a répondu tout à
l'heure ce qui ne serait exclue d'emblée
de la reprise du pays
or 11 mai des activités tels que les
restaurants les bars etc
donc il a posé un cadre un cadre général
il a posé une date et j'entends ici que
tout le monde a salué le cap donné par
le président de la république
j'entendais la question posée par madame
küster tout à l'heure qui saluait le cap
qui avait été donnée par le prix dans la
république et premier ministre a répondu
dans le détail sur les conditions qui
doivent désormais être remplie qui nous
permettront de tenir ce cap
un débat parlementaire vous en aurez
monsieur corps bien toutes les semaines
nous sommes présents et vous aurez un
débat parlement
r sur par exemple l'utilisation d'un
outil numérique au service de la lutte
contre la propagation du virus sur le
territoire national c'est aussi les mots
du président de la république hier enfin
sur la question des tests des symptômes
j'ai déjà répondu deux fois
si vous testez tout le monde un jour
donné admettons vous ayez 60 millions de
tests pcr à faire des prélèvements
ça ne dit rien de l'état c'est le de
l'état de santé des personnes que vous
avez testé le lendemain ce n'est pas
l'alpha et l'oméga tester les personnes
symptomatique les personnes contacts
mais oui c'est ce que nous recommandons
de faire nommer m et c'est ce que font
tous les pays les plus avancés en la
matière merci monsieur le ministre la
parole est à madame marie george buffet
pour le groupe de la gauche démocrate et
républicaine
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre il ya soit le président
de la république a ouvert la voie à une
levée du confinement le 11 mai sont
vraiment lever les inquiétudes et des
garanties suffisantes concernant les
conditions sanitaires et sociales de
sortir de crise ce week-end encore le
président du medef a proposé que les
français travaillent plus dès la fin du
confinement
ces propos indignes ne sont pas à la
hauteur vous en conviendrez de l'épisode
connaît notre pays et témoigne de l'état
de l'esprit de certains prêts à faire
payer aux salariés les conséquences
économiques de cette crise sans
précédent la santé de chacun de nos
compatriotes doit primer sur toute autre
considération
il n'est pas acceptable que les salariés
continuent de se rendre sur leur lieu de
travail sans bénéficier des équipements
de protection nécessaires
qu'en sera-t-il dans quatre semaines
l'etat sera t-il en capacité de fournir
les tests et les masses pour garantir la
sécurité sanitaire de tous les salariés
s'écrie vrai rappelle les inégalités
sociales dont avait parlé monsieur le
ministre
importante qui se joue au sein du monde
du travail les salariés les plus exposés
sont souvent les moins bien rénumérés
beaucoup d'autres subissent qu'une perte
importante de pouvoir d'achat en raison
d'un chômage partiel indemnisé à 84 % du
salaire net et une hausse des prix à la
consommation
si l'annoncé hier soir d'être ciblées en
faveur des familles et des étudiants
modestes par le président de la
république va dans le bon sens cela est
loin d'être suffisant
le les confinements doit s'accompagner
pour les plus fragiles d'actes forts en
matière de sécurité sanitaire de pouvoir
d'achat et de solidarité il convient
sans plus attendre
enter les prestations sociales de mieux
indemniser le chômage partiel est de
revaloriser le smic de façon importante
monsieur le premier ministre
quand allez vous inscrire à l'ordre du
jour ces propositions je vois bien merci
chers collègues la parole est à monsieur
olivier ferrand ministre des solidarités
et de la santé madame la députée
marie-george buffet d'abord merci
d'avoir souligné vous même l'annoncé par
le chef de l'état hier qu'il y aurait
une prime accordée aux personnes qui
vivent en situation de précarité aux
familles aux étudiants qui rencontrent
des situations sociales extrêmement
difficile une prime dont les contours
seront annoncées prochainement et qui
vient enrichir l'ensemble des
dispositifs déjà pris par ce
gouvernement sans attendre de manière à
protéger les plus fragiles je pourrais
vous en faire la liste elle serait très
longue
juste vous rappeler qu'il ya une
prolongation automatique des prestations
sociales pour les ayants droit sans
avoir besoin de démontrer qu'il était
toujours ayants droit qui eut la
prolongation de la trêve hivernale qu'il
y ait un soutien très fort aux
associations qui sur le terrain dans des
conditions difficiles et vous me donnez
l'occasion de les remercier en sincérité
pour l'action déterminée qu'il mène pour
protéger les plus précaires les sans
abri les personnes migrantes y compris
les travailleurs sociaux les indicateurs
sociaux qui font un travail absolument
remarquable et qui n'ont jamais failli
qui n'ont jamais failli depuis premier
jour madame même un george buffet mme
depuis le premier jour de cette épidémie
de cette pandémie
c'est la santé et c'est la seule santé
qui a été la boussole du gouvernement
dans toutes les décisions qui ont été
prises c'est la santé et c'est à nouveau
la santé qui a été l' indicateur le
critère majeur sur lequel s'est fondé le
discours du président de la république
hier à l'heure d'aborder le futur des
confinant il a parlé de la saturation
des réanimations il a parlait des
surcharges hospitalière il a parlé de la
nécessité absolue que nous restions
confinés dans les meilleures conditions
possibles pendant encore plusieurs
semaines pour permettre à nos soignants
de récupérer de la force de l'air de
l'énergie des médicaments des lits des
masques des matériels de protection et
enfin madame buffet
c'est important les tests et les masques
c'est important mais n'allons pas croire
que ce soit l'alpha et l'oméga de la
politique sanitaire de prévention ou
d'interventions en période d'épidémie
dans notre pays c'est bien plus que ça
et c'est notamment l' exploit
remarquable qu'ont réalisé nos hôpitaux
pour se transformer pour se transformer
se transcender me permet de sauver des
milliers de vie dans notre pays
merci monsieur le ministre la parole et
à madame brigitte kuster pour le groupe
l'est républicain
merci monsieur le président ma question
donc s'adresse normalement ministre de
l'économie et je la pose à nouveau nom
de tous mes collègues les républicains
si l'extension du confinement paraît
sage elle prolonge également l' angoisse
de l'ensemble des chefs d'entreprise et
des indépendants de notre pays qui
craignent des faillites en cascade avec
des conséquences désastreuses pour
l'emploi le président vient de reprendre
notre proposition que nous avions
formulées au nom du groupe l'est
républicain d'annuler les charges
d'entreprise les plus touchées détendre
et de simplifier les dispositifs
existants nous allons donc ici cette
volonté du président aussi par ailleurs
d'insister ou d'inciter plus exactement
les assurances à faire beaucoup plus
pour sauver les pme et les tpe mais
d'assez par de lourdes pertes
d'exploitation de tels gestes sont
évidemment les bienvenus mais ne seront
pas suffisants pour préserver notre
tissu économique
en effet les cafés les hôtels les
restaurants on a pris donc hier qu'ils
resteront fermées après le 11 mai
monsieur le ministre
êtes vous prêt à mettre sur la table un
grand plan de soutien à destination des
cafés hôtels restaurants
c'est à dire pour l'ensemble du secteur
touristique et également pour le secteur
événementiel eux aussi au besoin de
visibilité sur leurs dates de
réouverture
quel est le calendrier envisagé enfin
nous devons changer d'échelle dans le
soutien de l'état à notre activité
économique très fortement menacée je
vais prendre un exemple l'allemagne
l'allemagne
elle garantit ces prêts bancaires à 100%
l'allemagne prévoit des aides pouvant
aller jusqu'à 15 mhz
ils euros pour les petits commerces et
les pme quand les aides de la france
vous le savez sont cinq fois plus faible
je rappelle aussi que l'allemagne va
injecter 200 milliards d'euros pour
soutenir son industrie
quand nous n'avons prévu qu'une
enveloppe de 22 ans messieurs le
ministre le compte n'y est pas êtes-vous
donc prêt à les moeurs vers soutenir les
entreprises de notre pays
je vous remercie bien pour une question
qui ne vous rêvez pas tout à fait de la
santé la parole est à madame agnès venir
in hd secrétaire d'état auprès du
ministre de l'économie et des finances
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés
madame la députée küster oui vous avez
raison le plan que nous avons mis en
place est en train de se développer et
de se renforcer je veux le dire ici
le projet de loi de finances
rectificative sur lequel vous allez être
amené à vous prononcer dans les
prochains jours complète un premier plfr
et c'est ensemble près de 110 milliards
d'euros qui sont mis à disposition de
ces toutes petites entreprises mais
également des entreprises industrielles
des entreprises du tourisme des
entreprises de la restauration et de
tous les secteurs d'activité ainsi que
des associations pour faire en sorte de
limiter au maximum la casse sociale
je veux rappeler ici qu'il y a neuf cent
mille entreprises qui bénéficient
aujourd'hui du fonds de solidarité pour
un premier chèque de 1500 euros mais
comme vous le savez c'est 2000 euros
additionnel auxquelles elles peuvent
prétendre dès le 15 avril et pour le
mois d'avril elles pourront bénéficier à
nouveau de 1500 euros et d'un montant
additionnel qui pourra aller jusqu'à
5000 euros si vous votez nos
propositions ce qui fait mis bout-à-bout
pour certaines entreprises
dix mille euros dix mille euros et je
crois que c'est un montant important
pour les tpe
s'agissant du chômage partiel c'est mam
4 milliards d'euros et un dispositif qui
je crois se compare très favorablement
justement au à nos voisins européens
vous avez cité à l'allemagne on peut en
citer d'autres qui permet de maintenir
le lien entre lens le salarié et
l'entreprise est de justement protéger
ses salariés de façon à ce que au moment
de la reprise
ils puissent être là enfin je veux être
clair oui il y aura un plan spécifique
j'étais tout à l'heure à 13h avec l'umih
les hôteliers la restauration pour
évoquer les bases de ce plan nous avons
trois actions une première action c'est
de faire en sorte que très vite on
apporte des réponses pour que les
dirigeants de ces entreprises ne se
désespère pas et ne dépose pas ensuite
de leur permettre de reprendre de
manière très sécurisée et on y travaille
et enfin de leur apporter le soutien qui
sera un soutien à plus long terme compte
tenu des spécificités de la mer si la
ministre la parole est à monsieur le
président jean christophe lagarde du
groupe u10 agir et indépendant merci
monsieur le président nos collègues
ultramarins sont empêchés de rejoindre
la métropole et c'est donc au nom de nos
collègues de nouvelle calédonie et de
polynésie française philippe dunoyer
philippe gomes maina sage et nicole sans
cesse anker pardon que je vous pose
cette question de jeu le premier nice la
pandémie a aussi atteint même si c'est
heureusement un degré moindre les
collectivités françaises du pacifique
aujourd'hui 55 cas ont été confirmés en
polynésie et 18 en nouvelle calédonie
c'est pourquoi les instituts sur le call
en lien avec l'êta ont décidé de
prolonger le confinement
jusqu'au 19 avril pour la nouvelle
calédonie où 29 avril pour la polynésie
les conséquences de la pandémie dans ces
territoires sont économiquement terrible
et touche le coeur même de leur
principale activité le tourisme pour la
polynésie
l'industrie du nickel pour la nouvelle
calédonie votre gouvernement a fait
bénéficier ses collectivités de
dispositifs nationaux notamment l'accès
au fonds de solidarité ainsi que la
garantie de l'état aux prêts accordés
aux entreprises
toutefois aucun de ces deux territoires
ne sont admis au financement de
l'indemnisation des régimes de chômage
partiel instaurées au plan national dans
la mesure où ces collectivités étant
compétente en la matière ont instauré
leur propre dispositif de chômage
partiel se pose donc deux questions sur
lequel ils veulent attirer votre
attention
au plan sanitaire la nouvelle calédonie
est sans doute un peu plus tard la
polynésie devrait s'engager dans des
stratégies de déconfinement plus tôt que
les autres régions françaises y compris
les départements d'outre-mer or ces
collectivités ne disposent pas
aujourd'hui de masques en nombre
suffisant pour organiser le
déconfinement dans les conditions posées
par le président de la république hier
soir pouvez vous vous engagez à leur en
donner les moyens matériels nécessaires
indé confinement
qui garantissent la sécurité sanitaire
des populations au plan économique la
nouvelle calédonie et la polynésie
française doivent signer prochainement
les prêts de trésorerie garantis par
l'état permettant notamment
l'indemnisation des chômeurs mais ces
prêts conduiront l'endettement de ces
collectivités à un niveau extrêmement
élevé qui ne leur permettra pas de
financer des plans de relance économique
qui s'imposeront puisque contrairement à
l'état ces collectivités locales ont
l'obligation elle de présenter des
budgets en équilibre au titre de la
solidarité nationale le gouvernement
peut-il s'engager à transformer ses
prêts en concours financier exceptionnel
accordé à ces territoires ce que la
france fait pour 70 millions de français
peut-elle le fait le faire pour les 600
mille de nos concitoyens du pacifique
merci monsieur le président la parole
monsieur le premier ministre monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
députés monsieur le président lagarde
interrogée sur les conséquences de
l'épidémie de kovy de 19 sur les les
territoires ultra marins du pacifique la
polynésie wallis et futuna et la
nouvelle calédonie d'abord comme vous je
veux dire qu' aucun de ces territoires
heureusement ne se trouve en stade 3 de
l'épidémie et que même s'il ya des cas
dans chacun de ces territoires
ils ont à ce stade pu être contenue et
c'est plutôt une excellente nouvelle
je veux dire aussi que dès le début de
l'épidémie nous avons pris soin alors
même que le la présence du virus et la
circulation de virus sur ces territoires
étaient considérablement moins nette de
procéder aux décisions de confinement de
façon à les préserver
puisque nous savons qu'ils sont j'allais
dire intrinsèquement plus fragile compte
tenu de l'éloignement compte tenu des
faiblesses parfois de leur système
hospitalier leur système de soins en
général
donc oui évidemment il ya un impact sur
les économies locales comme en vérité
sur l'ensemble du monde
le tourisme essentiellement pour la
polynésie l'industrie minière et celle
du nickel en particulier en nouvelle
calédonie très tôt nous avons pris la
décision et comment aurait-il pu en
aller autrement de faire jouer
pleinement la solidarité nationale à
l'égard de nos concitoyens d'outre-mer
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous avons
accompagné les efforts des systèmes
hospitaliers locaux comptent consistant
à augmenter leurs capacités d'accueil
pour reproduire dans les territoires
ultramarins quel que soit leur statut la
même stratégie que celle qui était
développée au niveau national et dans la
même façon nous allons essayer de
fournir le maximum d'équipements
nécessaires à ces territoires
ultramarins
avec cette différence spécifiques vous
le connaissez du fait que la compétence
est souvent est souvent attribuée au
territoire et que l'état peut venir en
support mais pas en remplacement sous
peine de poser des questions voire des
interrogations qui dépasserait assez
largement la gestion de l'épidémie
ce que je veux vous confirmer monsieur
le président la garde c'est que le
projet de loi de finances rectificative
qui sera présenté demain en conseil des
ministres et qui viendra à l'examen en
séance vendredi à l'assemblée nationale
contiendra en effet une disposition
permettant à l'état de garantir les
emprunts consentis par le territoire de
nouvelle calédonie afin de mettre en
place un dispositif équivalent au
chômage partiel tel que nous le
connaissons en métropole c est tout sauf
anecdotique puisque cela va permettre au
territoire dans l'exercice de sa
compétence et sans se substituer à lui
ce qui est important c'est même
peut-être encore plus important nouvelle
calédonie qu'ailleurs ça va permettre à
la nouvelle qu'elle vient de mettre en
place un dispositif nouveau qui va
accompagner la vie poser la question de
savoir si cette garantie d'emprunt doit
être transformé le moment venu dans
quelque chose qui relèveraient au fonds
de financement direct par la
collectivité
le des dispositions mises en place par
le territoire de nouvelles qualités le
moment venu peut-être que cette question
sera évoquée
vous comprenez bien que notre objectif
est de répondre très rapidement à une
demande était formulée très clairement
par les représentants du territoire
cette garantie d'emprunt permet à
l'évidence à la nouvelle qu'elle est
digne de mettre en place le dispositif
rapidement et dans des conditions de
financement garanti et vous savez que
l'équilibré des comptes en matière
sociale sur le territoire n'était pas
totalement acquis n'est toujours pas
totalement acquis la garantie vient
compenser cela et vient permettre
d'avancer
quant à savoir les conséquences qui
conviendra de tirer vis-à-vis de la
polynésie ou de la nouvelle calédonie ou
de wallis et futuna de l'impact de cette
crise sanitaire dans les comptes des
relations financières dans
l'organisation des pouvoirs publics
je pense que cette question devrait être
abordée mais qu'il est prématuré de le
faire aujourd'hui et que la bordée par
tel ou tel aspect qui serait peut-être
un peu non pas du tout anecdotique mais
qui ne serait pas un aspect global
pourrait faire encore et le risque d'une
vision un peu déséquilibré vous savez
comme moi que dans ces territoires ce
qui est important c'est d'avoir une
vision parfaitement équilibré et si
possible consensuelle si on veut avancer
loin merci monsieur le premier ministre
la parole est à monsieur sébastien
nadeau députés non inscrits merci
monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre en représentant de la
nation j'ai roulé longtemps depuis mes
terres occitanes pour venir vous
délivrer plusieurs messages je suis
d'abord venu vous dire la douleur des
familles endeuillées la terrible
angoisse des proches des malades
la peur d'être abandonnés des plus
fragiles et parfois malheureusement leur
abandon les plus vulnérables
physiquement socialement et
économiquement sont en première ligne en
france chez tous les pays européens
comme chez nos plus proches voisins du
continent africain je veux vous dire
ensuite toute l'admiration le soutien et
les encouragements aux initiatives et
mobilisations sans relâche des
combattants du quotidien soignants
bénévoles et autres acteurs essentiels
ce qu'on applaudit tous les
soir à 20h à son tour la communauté
scientifique s'est mise en ordre de
bataille aux côtés du ministère de la
santé que je salue au ministère de la
recherche
pour éclairer et bientôt même à portée
des premières solutions pour faire face
à la crise du coronavirus mais cela ne
suffit pas à l'heure de la grande
défiance
il nous faut de la confiance à l'heure
du plongeon dans l'inconnu
il nous faut de la transparence dans les
décisions politiques à l'heure du
discours d'un seul il nous faut aussi un
vrai débat démocratique
monsieur le premier ministre je ne peux
pas me résoudre à voir twitter bfm au
quotidien remplacer condorcet jaurès et
simone veil le petit député que je suis
vous demande d'aller dire au président
de la république qu'il faut vite réunir
un congrès extraordinaire depuis
versailles rassemblant toutes les forces
représentatives de la nation en
s'inspirant de la convention pour le
climat comment utiliser notre
intelligence collective pour reconnaître
nos erreurs et en faire une force
comment protéger les plus faibles avec
quel système fiscal
comment concilier santé et libertés à
l'ère du numérique
comment relancer l'économie sans
continué d'agresser notre environnement
comment changer de gouvernance vers
celle qui servirait l'intérêt général
celle qui éviterait la prédation des
ressources de notre planète
monsieur le premier ministre de battre
le coeur de la démocratie s'est presque
arrêtée irez vous dire au président la
république que le débat d'aujourd'hui
construire à demain merci monsieur le
député en tout cas l'assemblée nationale
elle continue à travailler à contrôler
le gouvernement et évaluer les
politiques publiques et à adopter des
lois
j'ajoute que la réunion d'un congrès
enfreindre est sans doute le seuil au
delà duquel il est interdit de se réunir
c'est à dire 50 la parole à monsieur
olivier ferrante ministre des
solidarités et de la santé merci
monsieur le président monsieur le député
nadeau je crois que le président de
l'assemblée nationale a tout dit s'il y
avait des velléités de congrès à
versailles
rassemblant quelques 900 et quelques
parlementaires vous comprendrez aisément
qu'il serait à la fois peu
compréhensibles pour la population est à
la fois peu admissible pour les
parlementaires
ainsi réunies et je ne parle pas de tous
les fonctionnaires qui seraient ainsi
mobilisés de justifier un tel congrès en
l'instant par contre monsieur nadeau
vous avez raison de vouloir maintenir
vif le coeur battant de la démocratie je
crois que la présence du premier
ministre
à chaque séance de questions au
gouvernement que ce soit l'assemblée
nationale ou au sénat
semaine après semaine en est une
démonstration je crois que le débat que
nous avons eu qui a duré à l'assemblée
nationale et au sénat sur l'état
d'urgence sanitaire est une autre
démonstration je crois que l'annoncé par
le président de la république d'un débat
démocratique à venir et donc d'un débat
parlementaire à venir sur les questions
des outils numériques dead à la lutte
contre l'épidémie est un autre argument
supplémentaire
je pourrais vous faire la liste mais des
cartes disait le risque d'ennuyer c'est
de vouloir tout dire je voudrais pas
tout dire simplement rappeler que rien
que pour la seule semaine passée nous
avons organisé avec le 1er mai le
premier ministre à organiser et j'ai eu
la chance d'y assister
des réunions en visioconférence ou en
audio conférence une avec les présidents
de tous les partis politiques une autre
avec les présidents ddd groupe et de
gestion des collectivités territoriales
une autre avec les présidents des
différents groupes parlementaires
je vous garantis que dans l'agenda qui
est le nôtre la place conférer légitime
et c'est normal à l'ensemble de la
représentation nationale et des élus me
semble être garante du bon
fonctionnement de nos institutions
monsieur nadeau je me propose d'aller
regarder chez sur un certain nombre de
nos voisins
comment se porte le parlementarisme vous
verrez que non seulement la france n'a
pas à rougir mais je crois même qu'elles
peuvent se targuer de s'illustrer dans
la période par le maintien constante et
d'institutions et j'en remercie
notamment le président de l'assemblée
nationale
merci monsieur le ministre nous
poursuivons maintenant en pré-séance
avait des questions portant sur des
thèmes économiques et sociaux
la parole était madame brigitte kuster
pour le groupe l'est républicain
monsieur le président ayant inversé tout
à l'heure mais question et y aura fait
la question économie alors la question
santé vous m'excuserez et donc je vais
faire maintenant la question santé mais
comme les mini sont ici présents et ne
m'en voudront pas voir là mais se
verront elle a tout le temps donc c'est
merveilleux et donc monsieur verront
même si vous avez déjà répondu en partie
sur le dépistage permettez moi quand
même de me faire l'écho de la question
que mes collègues voulais vous poser au
premier rang desquels d'ailleurs michèle
tabarot et bernard brochand sur la
politique de dépistage
je reviendrai peut-être pas sur les
chiffres mais comme la 15000 morts dans
notre pays avec le diagnostic par les
thèses qui fait cruellement encore
défaut on est nombreux à le dire ici est
une stratégie de dépistage qui excusez
nous continuer à nous interroger
nous sommes malheureusement en train de
revivre avec les tests de dépistage le
même manque d'anticipation et la même
situation de pénurie que nous avons
connue avec les masques de protection
nous demandons donc un dépistage
systématique dans l'ensemble des ehpad
c'est la priorité numéro un pour les
personnels et pour les résidents
c'est absolument indispensable hélas le
président hier n'en a pas parlé
la solution dans les ehpad vous le savez
est un scandale dont le président ne
semble pas avoir suffisamment conscience
près de 5000 personnes sont mortes du
coronavirus et certains établissements
sont même décimés par des vagues
entières de décès absolument effrayante
par ailleurs faute de dépistage massif
dans l'immédiat la stratégie retenue de
l'isen dans systématique les nerfs des
situations de solitude voire de détresse
absolue et c'est la bonne nouvelle hier
que les visites puisse à un moment être
reprises un contact à ce dépistage en
fait donc systématique dans les ehpad
nous avons une autre inquiétude après le
11 mai le président n'envisage pas non
plus de tester les français qui
représenterait des symptômes du coït 19
pire encore il a dit hier cela n'aurait
aucun sens de tester tous les français
de tels propos nous inquiète au plus
haut point
alors que l'on sait qu'une part
importante des personnes touchées par le
coronavirus deux présentent aucun
symptôme
ce refus d'un dépistage bonheur
prenons la parole et à monsieur olivier
ferrand ministre des solidarités et de
la santé madame la députée questerre
comme j'ai eu l'occasion de répondre je
crois trois fois sur la question du
pourquoi vouloir dépister tout le monde
sans symptôme n'est pas indispensable je
vais me permettre de prendre un exemple
peut être le vôtre madame questerre
imaginons que vous me disiez aujourd'hui
je voudrais avoir un dépistage pcr j'ai
envie d'avoir ce test pour savoir je
n'ai pas de symptômes je ne connais
personne dans mon entourage proche
qu'ils soient malades mais je veux
connaître aujourd'hui à date la
possibilité que j'ai d'être malade
imaginons que nous ayons ainsi la
capacité de réaliser 60 millions de
tests pcr par jours ce qu'aucun pays au
monde même en réunissant l'ensemble des
pays de ce monde ne serait capable de
réaliser
imaginons madame questeur que néanmoins
je vous dise très bien on va vous
dépister
vous êtes négatives même que ce terre
vous n'avez pas de symptômes n'avait pas
été en contact avec des personnes
malades
vous êtes donc négative et c'était
attendu d'accord demain vous revenez me
voir en me demandant j'ai pris le bus je
le suis promené dans la rue j'ai fait
des courses je veux savoir si je suis
positive ou négative et le jour suivant
aussi et le jour suivant aussi même
coaster ça n'a pas de sens le président
de la république a raison de le dire
ce qui est fondamental c'est que madame
la députée ce qui est fondamental c'est
que si vous avez de la fièvre de la toux
une personne de votre proche entourage
qui est malade et que vous poser
légitimement avec des indices permettant
de penser que vous êtes malade alors là
oui nous devons être en mesure de vous
tester et si vous êtes malades de
pouvoir vous isolez ça c'est quelque
chose qui est important et pardon
arrêtons de comparer en permanence la
situation française avec la situation
d'autres pays d'abord la france est le
seul pays à communiquer en transparence
toutes les données dont elle dispose je
vous dire on communique même des données
qui sont incomplètes en matière de
politique de tests si vous allez sur le
site de santé publique france vous
verrez qu'en dessous des chiffres des
laboratoires de ville il ya marqué
chiffres basés sur une enquête sur trois
laboratoires
il ya soixante dix laboratoires qui font
des tests man caster donc il est même
très probable que nous la france réalise
entre 150000 à 200000 test à dire bien
plus que ce que nous disons nous mêmes
et nous préférons donner les données
indiquer clairement les données non dits
dont nous disposons et quand vous
regardez en allemagne en réalité ils
sont entre 250 et 300 mille tests et
nous augmentons nos capacités pcr et
nous augmenterons encore dans les
semaines à venir
l'enjeu c'est d'être prêt pour pouvoir
dépister toutes personnes symptomatique
j'espère vous avoir merci monsieur le
ministre la parole de monsieur bruno
fuchs pour le groupe du mouvement
démocrate et apparentés merci monsieur
le président je souhaite tout d'abord au
nom du groupe modem et témoigner notre
soutien et notre solidarité envers nos
concitoyens et concitoyennes qui sont
jour et nuit en première ligne dans
cette crise avoir une pensée très émue
pour toutes les victimes de cette
maladie et en particulier mon ami
alsacien de bernard stalter président
national de la chambre des métiers
d'artisanat bernard est décédé hier
ducobu 19 il avait 63 ans
monsieur le ministre je souhaite vous
lira la question notre président patrick
mignola le 22 mars dernier nous votions
un plan d'envergure pour permettre à
l'économie à la justice à la solidarité
entre pays de faire face à la crise
sanitaire que nous affrontons sévriens
mesures ont déjà porté leurs fruits
aujourd'hui les salariés empêchés de
travailler sont au chômage partiel et
nous pourrons retrouver leur emploi
après la crise les indépendants
disposent d'une ressource d'urgence les
entreprises ont les moyens de faire face
à leurs difficultés de trésorerie
évidemment les dispositifs mis en place
car encore être amélioré et beaucoup
reste à faire pour s'adapter à de
multiples situations particulières qui
soit accessible à toutes et à tous
beaucoup reste à faire par exemple pour
que les banques et les assurances joue
mieux le jeu pour que les fonds de
solidarité soient renforcés pour que les
prêts garanties d'état soient mises en
oeuvre
quelle que soit la situation des
entreprises hier le président de la
république nous a invités à compléter ce
premier arsenal pour que tout le monde
quelle que soit sa situation puisse
bénéficier du soutien le plus efficace
personne ne sera oublié
c'est le message fondamental pour nos
compatriotes pour ces raisons notre
groupe accompagnera le gouvernement dans
le renforcement et l'application de ces
mesures
parce que c'est aussi le rôle de la
représentation nationale sur la base du
vécu et du ressenti des députés
quels que soient leur banc conformément
aux annonces du président de la
république
nous avons deux semaines pour concevoir
le plan de sortie de l'après 11 mai mais
avant le 11 mai il ya d'abord les jours
qui viennent monsieur le ministre ma
question sera double comment
comptez-vous mettre en oeuvre les
annonces de solidarité proposé hier et
en particulier toutes celles concernant
les familles les plus modestes et par
quels moyens
pensez vous pouvoir rendre merlus
d'elijah ce qu'elle voulait voir les
ministres mes chers collègues faites
attention parce que c'est pas parce que
nous sommes moins nombreux qu'il faut
que tout le monde fasse systématiquement
plus long yen qui dérapages aussi pour
moi monsieur le président national
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés monsieur le député
vous évoquez le soutien nécessaire de la
nation à ceux de ses acteurs qui sont le
plus impacté par la crise
la vérité vraie c'est que quasiment tout
le monde est impacté par la crise tout
le monde est impacté par l'impact du
confinement tout le monde est touché je
veux dire par là peine l'angoissent le
deuil parfois
lié à ce confinement sanitaire mais
chacun sent bien que l'impact économique
de ce confinement que l'impact
économique de du choc
redoutable sur la demande mondiale sur
la demande française qui va suivre ce
confinement va être ressenti par nos
concitoyens par les entreprises par les
salariés de ces entreprises par les
professions indépendantes par les
artisans par professions libérales bref
bref partout le monde par les artistes
par ce qui contribua au monde du
spectacle vivant que sais-je encore par
tout le monde
l'objectif initial du gouvernement
à côté de ce que vous avez indiqué ça a
été de faire en sorte que pendant la
période du confinement nous soyons en
mesure de permettre au maximum d'acteurs
économiques de survivre à ce confinement
sanitaires c'est la raison pour laquelle
peut-être le dit ont trop peu le
gouvernement c'est vrai le dit souvent
mais peut-être que trop peu en ont
conscience
nous avons mis en place un mécanisme que
nous avons d'ailleurs conçu en apprenant
de ce qui s'était fait en 2008 de la
grande crise financière de 2008
nous avons conçu un mécanisme de
d'activité partielle d'indemnisation du
chômage partiel qui le plus généreux
c'est un fait en europe parce que nous
avons appris en 2008 et la situation
était redoutable mans compliqué en 2008
aussi d'une certaine façon qu'il fallait
faire en sorte non pas de rembourser le
moment venu les entreprises d avance qu
elle devait consentir pendant la crise
pour aller vite mais bien leur permettre
de passer au mieux la crise pour ne
conserver leurs compétences on pourra
repartir ensuite au fond en 2008 les
allemands avaient mieux que nous su
préserver cette capacité productive
grâce à un mécanisme plus généreux que
le nôtre nous avons voulu cette année si
j'ose dire
à l'occasion de cette crise sanitaire
nous prémunir contre cet inconvénient
est créé ce système qui est
effectivement plus généreux généreux
pour les entreprises c'est vrai mais
généreux pour les salariés puisque la
rémunération nette du salarié reste
c'est vrai elle subit un impact mais
reste à un niveau assez largement
supérieure à ce qui prévaut en allemagne
notamment
à côté de ce chômage partiel le fonds de
solidarité qu'ils rencontrent c'est vrai
un très grand succès et ce qu'il est
parfait non est ce que il permet à toute
entreprise qui en bénéficient de se dire
il ya plus de problème non bien sûr mais
il existe il est incroyablement
sollicité et il permet c'est vrai un
certain de l'entreprise d'avoir une
bouffée d'oxygène qui leur permet de
tenir pendant la durée du confinement
ces mesures vont être encore approfondi
et ce sera l'objet du projet de loi de
finances rectificative qui sera présenté
demain en conseil des ministres et qui
sera débattu vendredi à l'assemblée
nationale que de permettre un abondement
de crédit un dispositif encore
supérieure avec une amélioration d'un
certain nombre de dispositifs je pense
par exemple à l'amendement de crédits du
fonds de développement économique et
social qui va permettre de venir aider
un certain de l'entreprise qui sans quoi
se retrouver dans des situations un pays
donc pour les entreprises l'impact
maximal la volonté de les préserver et
total le prix d'un public hier a indiqué
que pour pour nos concitoyens et
singulièrement pour nos concitoyens les
plus démunis ou les plus fragiles ceux
qui se trouvent en fin de droits ceux
qui sont bénéficiaires du rsa les
familles dont les membres actifs se
trouvent avec très peu de moyens et avec
plusieurs enfants tous ceux là doivent
également être accompagnés dans l'impact
que représente pour eux le confinement
et ce sera l'objet là aussi d'une
enveloppe qui sera contenue dans le
projet de loi de finances rectificative
qui sera soumis demain en conseil des
ministres j'aurai l'occasion monsieur le
député pardonnez moi après en avoir
évoqué les dispositions et les avoir
présenté au conseil des ministres
j'aurai l'occasion de présenter à la
représentation nationale et au grand
public nous comprendre et je pense qu'il
me reviennent d'abord de les faire
adopter par le conseil des ministres
avant de pouvoir en détailler l'ensemble
des dispositions
je veux simplement vous indiquer que
nous sommes parfaitement conscients de
la nécessité que le président la
république a demandé un versement sans
délai que notre objectif c'est de faire
en sorte que les familles et les
individus les plus fragiles puissent
bénéficier de cette aide à l'horizon du
mois de mai de la milieu du mois de mai
donc de faire en sorte que cela puisse
se passer vite et bien merci monsieur le
premier ministre monsieur dominique
potier pour le groupe socialiste et
apparentés merci monsieur le président
monsieur le premier ministre nous ne
sortirons pas tous égaux du confinement
le 11 mai au plus tard
nous le savons aujourd'hui et c'est ceux
qui se battent au quotidien auprès de
ceux qui souffrent dans n'osaient pas
dans les associations caritatives dans
les syndicats qui le disent le plus fort
ce qui se bat aujourd'hui voit ceux qui
souffrent et qui nous disent à quel
point une part d'inégalités malgré le
mouvement de charité malgré l'engagement
et la conscience professionnelle va
amplifier ces inégalités qui précédait
le confinement ne sortiront pas tous
égaux il ya quelque part quelque chose
d'indécent une atteinte à ce que george
orwell appelait la décence commune dans
les propos du président du medef lorsque
il ne sommes quelque part les
travailleurs français de faire des
efforts qu'il prévient qu'ils auront à
travailler plus qu'ils auront à
travailler autrement dans les écuries
il ya juste un effet de contre temps qui
est terrible alors que des millions de
français craignent pour leur pouvoir
d'achat
d'autres millions de français pour leur
emploi que d'autres sont dans une
situation de seuil de pauvreté qui sont
atteints aujourd'hui il ya quelque chose
de profondément indécent
toutes les périodes de rupture toutes
les périodes de conquête de notre
société où elle a grandi ont été
précédées de mouvements de justice
important pas de charité mais de justice
il n'y a qu'à relire si nous reprenons
là les références historiques du prêt
évoquée par le président la république
hier celle bien sûr de la déclaration de
1789 elle était du 27 août et ses
quelques jours avant le 4 août que nous
avons lits sont les privilèges c'est
plutôt le temps d'abolir les privilèges
que de réclamer un effort nouveau au
pays
et puis il y à une autre date importante
c'est celle du des jours heureux et du
conseil national de la résistance est à
ce moment là vous le savez 2 mars 44 à
avril mai 45 toutes les déclarations des
résistants font appel à la question de
la justice sociale que meurent
fondatrices de notre société
ces discours monsieur le premier ce que
nous avons besoin d'entendre aujourd'hui
le président a invité à nous réinventer
alors écoutons nous écouter les
propositions que nous portons
c'est pas la charité nous avons besoin
c'est de la justice qui permettra
l'effort non pas pour simplement
reconstruire mais pour refonder notre
société notre économie de notre pays
merci chers collègues rapport notamment
à muriel pénicaud ministre du travail
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés
monsieur le député je crois que vous
l'avez dit on a besoin de justice on a
besoin de cohésion dans l'époque où
somme c'est aussi par l'unité de la
nation c'est par le fait de traverser
cette épreuve tous ensemble que nous
réussirons
vous avez évoqué la situation des
entreprises et du travail je voudrais
revenir sur ce point avec les
partenaires sociaux tous les deux jours
nous avons une réunion téléphonique ou
évidemment nous abordons le sujet de
santé et de sécurité des travailleurs de
chômage partiel mais aussi des
conditions de travail des conditions de
reprise dans le monde du travail
je voudrais saluer ici l'esprit de
responsabilité dans l'ensemble des
partenaires sociaux sur ce sujet
qu'est-ce qui se passe il se passe que
sur le terrain il y à une reprise
progressive mesurée en fonction des
mesures de santé et de sécurité du
travail qui sont mis en place dans
certains secteurs l'industrie tourne
aujourd'hui à 50%
le bâtiment est passé de 15 à 25% c'est
encore très modeste et évidemment après
le décor finement ça va s'amplifier
surtout à fur et à mesure des questions
de santé et de sécurité
alors dans ce contexte que ce que ça
veut dire en terme de travail des heures
du travail à certains secteurs qui
aujourd'hui sont bien en peine
l'activité je prends l'exemple de
l'automobile ou le sujet n'est pas de
travailler plus le sujet c'est quelle
activité peut repartir à quel moment
sachant qu effectivement aujourd'hui
dans le confinement est pas un français
qui va aller acheter une voiture et le
qu'on ne peut pas non plus produire des
milliers de voitures qui ne seront pas
vendus dans le secteur de l'automobile
il ya certaines équipes qui travaillent
notamment sur tout ce qui est réparation
maintenance est important pour les
ambulanciers c'est important pour les
chauffeurs livreurs qui de
l'agroalimentaire mais il ya aussi des
secteurs qui aujourd'hui s'organisent
par le dialogue social et ça c'est le
maître mot sur le terrain pour prendre
aujourd'hui par négociations salariales
des congés payés pour prendre des jours
de rtt des jours
quand j'ai pas le temps qui vont
permettre le moment venu là aussi par le
dialogue social et économique sur le
terrain s'il le faut de un moment donné
repartir plus fort mais je crois aussi
que le maître mot ça se décide pas d'en
haut ça se décide pas à paris il ya tous
les instruments et maintenant c'est par
le dialogue social sur le terrain qu'à
ce ça se fera dans l'intérêt évidemment
d'apporter les biens les services dont
les français aient besoin mais aussi que
les travailleurs soient partie prenante
de ce sujet merci madame la ministre
monsieur françois pour le groupe mais
quelque chose serait soumise de
l'économie et des finances nous
apprêtons à examiner un second budget
rectificatif qui doit adapter les
dispositifs d'urgence des dons
d'entreprise nous l'avons dit ces
dispositifs sont nécessaires nous avons
aussi relevé de la faiblesse de
certaines enveloppes et pointé les
manquements des ajustements seront
visiblement fait et c'est une bonne
chose pour élargir la garantie bancaire
de l'état ou augmenter les fonds de
solidarité
ces évolutions sont d'autant plus
nécessaires que des difficultés
demeurent sur le terrain pour l'accès
aux entreprises aux prêts garantis
souvent compte tenu de l'attitude des
banques aux fonds de soutien au chômage
partiel
il y aura dans un futur proche que nous
souhaitons un plan de relance et nous
estimons qu'il devra privilégier les
dimensions sociales environnementales et
de souveraineté économique par contre
entre le plan d'urgence et le plan de
relance que vous nous proposez que vous
mettez en oeuvre
il manque à votre arsenal un plan de
sauvetage pour les secteurs les plus
impactés ceux concernés par plus de
quatre mois de fermeture l'hôtellerie la
restauration la culture et
d'événementiel certes le président elle
évoqué hier est une bonne chose
un plan spécifique mais qu'il est urgent
de préciser plusieurs questions sur ce
plan comportera-t-il des annulations de
charge des aides pour les loyers et sur
la méthode
allez-vous faire le choix de concerter
les acteurs économiques les
organisations les parlementaires mais
aussi les collectivités territoriales et
locales en effet souvent dans les
territoires ruraux ce sont elles qui
depuis des années ont permis à ces
petits commerces de voir le jour et de
survivre avec leur disparition annoncée
se sont aussi 30 ans d'aménagement du
territoire qui s'écroule
enfin pour sauver ces entreprises nous
considérons indispensable que la perte
d'exploitation soit enfin couverte
ma question est donc simple l'état
est-il en capacité d'imposer aux
assurances de participer à la prise en
charge de cette perte d'exploitation et
s'il n'y parvient pas envisage-t-il de
porter seul
info perte d'exploitation pour ses
activités par ailleurs pour que ces
entreprises remettent en marche leur
outil de travail
il faut pour certaines d'entre elles
plusieurs semaines pour celles qui sont
tributaires de la saison estivale elles
sont nombreuses
l'annnonce de leur ouverture ne devra
pas tarder dans le cas contraire il faut
se préparer une année blanche ou plutôt
à une année noire
merci monsieur de député la parole à
madame agnès manière une hache et
secrétaire d'état auprès du ministre de
l'économie et des finances merci
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés monsieur le député
pupponi vous l'avais dit il ya un fond
un plan de d'urgence qui aujourd'hui
fonctionne et permet justement
d'accompagner un certain nombre
d'entreprises j'ai cité le chiffre tout
à l'heure 900 me leur entreprise qui
d'ores et déjà sont rentrés dans ce plan
s'agissant des tpe et il y un plan de
relance qui est en préparation
entre les deux il va falloir accompagner
des entreprises qui sont en grande
difficulté en grande difficulté parce
qu'elles n'ont pas de chiffre d'affaires
peu de perspectives de chiffre
d'affaires dans les quatre mois qui
viennent et une difficulté à faire face
à leurs charges fixes et c'est à ça que
nous travaillons aujourd'hui comment y
travaillons nous d'abord nous avons
élargi les conditions d'accès des
entreprises qui ont des situation
financière fragile je pense aux
entreprises en difficulté je pense aux
entreprises qui ont une notation banque
de france inférieure enfin inférieure
est donc supérieure à 5 plus c'est à
dire qu'ils sont en moins bonne posture
de notation que cinq plus de façon à ce
qu'elle puisse elle aussi avoir accès à
ces dispositifs c'est une négociation
que nous avons eues avec l'union
européenne et c'est ce sont des éléments
que vous allez être amenés à voter dans
les prochains jours je vais également
dire que nous avons activé une enveloppe
d'un milliard d'euros 1 milliard d'euros
2 dess vous connaissez ce dispositif il
était à 75 millions d'euros
auparavant il est aujourd'hui élargie
pour accompagner plus massivement les
entreprises en difficulté et surtout
pour accompagner les plus petites
d'entre elles puisque nous allons
déléguer une partie de cette enveloppe à
nos directs à nos services régionaux qui
comme vous le savez travaillant très
bonne intelligence avec les
collectivités locales au premier chef
les régions qui sont
à la manoeuvre sur le développement
économique et qui d'ores et déjà ont
prévu des mesures pour accompagner ces
entreprises
enfin s'agissant de l'ouverture nous
préparons la réouverture comme l'a dit
muriel pénicaud chaque activité à son
plan de rigueur et les restaurants
l'hôtellerie n'y échapperont pas ils ont
déjà commencé à travailler ça ne sera
probablement pas tout de suite mais nous
il faut enfin sur les assurances
ministre la parole est à monsieur alexis
corbière pour le groupe de la france
insoumise
merci président madame la ministre du
travail ces derniers jours à propos de
l'après confinement des déclarations en
deux ministres ont fortement inquiété
beaucoup de nos concitoyens je pense
autant à celle de madame agnès pannier
une hache et qui a déclaré le 11 avril
je la cite il faudra certainement
travailler plus que nous l'avons fait
avant monsieur bruno le maire à propos
des congés posés pendant le confinement
a dit que c'était préférable afin que
notre économie redémarre au lendemain de
la crise le président du medef ça a été
évoqué lui avait dit qu'il faudrait se
poser la question tout à du temps de
travail des jours fériés des congés
payés pour accompagner la crise
fort heureusement il ya quelques minutes
monsieur le président du medef a
considéré que le débat de son point de
vue était clos alors prescient ma
question madame la ministre la suivante
quel est votre avis comme ministre du
travail sur les déclarations notamment
de votre collègue qui doivent qui pense
que nous devons travailler plus pensez
vous comme ne se refera de bézieux que
ce débat est clos
et quelle est votre opinion sur la
possibilité que les salariés demain soit
invité à travailler plus et à perdre des
congés en les posant pendant la paire de
confinement car contraint effectivement
de répandre dans ces conditions qui ne
sont pas celles de congé bref le monde
d'après ne peut pas être celui
d'aujourd'hui empire ou alors
franchement vous n'avez pas compris ce
qui se passait le ressentiment de
beaucoup de nos concitoyens nos
concitoyens notamment les salariés ne
peut pas être victimes d'une double
peine à la fois les mauvais choix
économiques et sociaux qui ont été faits
notamment par votre gouvernement mais
aussi les précédents et demain qui doit
être amené e à réparer les fautes dont
ils ne sont que les victimes et
certainement pas les responsables c'est
avec un monde égoïste inégalitaire
qu'ils feront quelques exemples les
entreprises du cac 40 en france
distribue il ya 20 ans 30% leurs
bénéfices à leurs actionnaires
aujourd'hui elle en redistribue 70
ensemble la rémunération des
actionnaires a progressé 4 fois de plus
que celle des salariés aujourd'hui un
salarié travaille 45 jours pour
rémunérer les actionnaires
installer des entreprises du cac 40 en
1981 c'était seulement de neuf jours
bref va allons-nous rompre avec ce monde
là et allons nous engager vers un
nouveau partage des richesses
le président mâcon a dit qu'il fallait
savoir sortir des idéologies et nous
réinventer concrètement la réinvention
du gouvernement demain qui me rappelle
avec journée travaillent plus longtemps
monsieur dmrc ma parole est à madame
monique au ministre du travail pour deux
minutes
mais monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés monsieur le député
alexis corbière ou poser deux questions
celle du temps de travail est celle du
partage de la valeur si je résume
rapidement votre question d'abord je
voudrais redire une chose c'est que la
priorité pour pouvoir reprendre de façon
plus massive l'activité économique qui
est aujourd'hui très ralentie arrêté
dans certaines entreprises ralenti dans
d'autres c'est d'abord les conditions de
sortie de sécurité du travailleur ça ne
porte pas dans votre question mais je
leur dis et je voudrais dire que sur ce
sujet et services du ministère du
travail de l'inspection du travail sont
très mobilisés que les partenaires
sociaux nous signale lorsqu'il ya des
cas aberrant et ce qui nous permet de
avoir une action à la fois pro active en
publiant des guides de bonnes pratiques
qui sont validées par le ministère du
travail et 2000 sert la santé qui nous
permettent de faire les gestes barrière
métier par métier chauffeur-livreur
caissière et c est en même temps des
contrôles et nous faisons beaucoup de
contrôle qu'elles sont du travail pour
vérifier que ces mesures sont mises en
place mais la question que vous posez
c'est peu tout travail se doit-il avoir
lieu à n'importe quelle heure à
n'importe quel horaire eh bien je vais
vous dire il ya une chose qui s'appelle
le code du travail tout le code
rien que le code nous avons défini dans
le code du travail des règles et là par
exemple vous avez posé la question des
congés payés nous avons défini par une
ordonnance récente que si les employeurs
voulait présenter maintenant la prise de
congés dès maintenant et pas en posant
un mois al avance comme ils ont le droit
de le faire d'habitude à ce moment là il
fallait qu'ils aient un accord des
partenaires sociaux donc à un certain
nombre d'entreprises assez nombreuses
qui sont en train de négocier au qui ont
négocié la prise d'une
de congés perrier maintenant souvent
contre une contrepartie par exemple que
le chômage partiel puissent être portées
jusqu'à 100% il ya plusieurs cas dont
renault qui sont récents sur les jours
de rtt et les jours de ces effectivement
il ya une possibilité d'utiliser au
moins une semaine pendant le congé
partiel donc ce n'est pas un changement
des règles c'est une adaptation au
contexte
en revanche là où je suivrai le
président de la république l'a dit le
sujet du partage de la valeur qui a déjà
beaucoup progressé avec la loi pacte est
pour moi et pour nous de tout le
gouvernement un sujet essentiel je pense
que ce sujet
la parole est à madame brigitte kuster
pour le groupe le républicain merci
monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre de la
culture à qui je veux redire le plaisir
de le voir complètement rétabli et de le
retrouver ici dans cet hémicycle
monsieur le ministre lors de son
allocution le président a décidé
l'interdiction de tous les
rassemblements jusqu'à la mi juillet
d'ores et déjà plusieurs festivals ont
annoncé leur annulation celui des
vieilles charrues le in d'avignon
solidays et c'est cette crise que
connaît le monde culturel est lourde de
conséquences tant humaines qu'économique
les intermittents des artistes et toutes
les professions de la filière du
spectacle vivant attendent donc du
ministère de la culture une parole forte
et des mesures à la hauteur des enjeux
tant sur un calendrier de sortie de
crise que sur les moyens et en place
pour sauvegarder ce secteur la cellule
d'assistance aux organisateurs de
festivals mise en place ne peut pas
constituer la seule réponse à l'une des
pires crises que nous ayons eu à
affronter au cours des dernières
décennies
comme vous le savez bien sûr le secteur
culturel et l'industrie du spectacle
font vivre de très nombreux métiers qui
sont aujourd'hui très gravement menacé
ainsi plusieurs questions se posent
qu'en est il du chômage partiel pour les
intermittents du spectacle puisque cela
revient à demander à des entreprises
déjà exemple de faire la vence des
rémunérations alors que le fonds mis en
place par l'état aurait pu indemnisées
directement les artistes et techniciens
qu'en est il de la situation des auteurs
elle aussi particulièrement inquiétante
ils ne bénéficient en effet d'aucun
revenu fixe et les spectacles sont
annulés les uns après les autres
quelle mesure monsieur ministre comptez
vous prendre pour leur venir en aide
concernant la filière cinématographique
ses représentants vous le savez apple
aller plus loin que l'utilisation des
fonds de soutien
autorisé par le cnc après un mois de
fermeture les pertes
évidemment sont importantes alors que ce
ministre le monde de la culture est un
monde sinistre et vous le savez pouvez
vous nous éclairer aujourd'hui sur les
mesures spécifiques que vous pouvez
prendre pour leur venir en aide
nous comptons sur vous et je vous
remercie merci chers collègues la part
de monsieur franck riester ministre de
la culture
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés et madame la
députée küster merci de votre question
effectivement tous les secteurs
d'activité sont touchés durement par
cette crise
ducobu 19 et tout particulièrement le
secteur de la culture avec des
conséquences économiques sociales
humaines artistique très importante vous
les avez rappelé et aujourd'hui j'ai une
pensée pour tous ces artistes et acteurs
de la culture qui non seulement voilà
les conséquences économiques et sociales
très lourdes pour leur activité pour
eux-mêmes mais aussi des conséquences
psychologiques artistique puisque
travailler à préparer des spectacles des
festivals pendant des mois voire des
années et devoir y renoncer
c'est évidemment se voir le coeur brisé
et je pense aujourd'hui à eux nous avons
dès le départ travailler sous l'autorité
du premier ministre avec mes collègues
du gouvernement pour que toutes les
mesures de portée générale puisse
bénéficier au secteur de la culture bien
évidemment tant les prêts garantis par
l'état pour les entreprises en matière
de trésorerie que l'accès au chômage
partiel pour les entreprises qui
recrutent des intermittents du spectacle
que le fonds de solidarité
et vous avez vu que ce fonds va avoir
son nom tant augmenté et ses modalités
d'accès revue pour que davantage
d'artistes auteurs puissent en
bénéficier
nous avons mobilisé les opérateurs du
ministère de la culture que pour que
tout de suite et puisse y avoir des
aides concrètes apportées aux acteurs de
la culture hauteur de 22 millions
d'euros mais ce n'est pas suffisant bien
évidemment le président de la république
nous a invités à bâtir un plan
spécifique pour la culture je vais y
travailler avec mes équipes avec les
ministres du gouvernement qui sont
directement impliqué aussi dans ce plan
sous l'autorité du premier
en lien avec les collectivités
territoriales en lien avec les
parlementaires et bien sûr en lien avec
les acteurs du secteur pour bâtir un
projet de relance un projet spécifique à
la hauteur du sinistre que aujourd'hui
heureux sans la culture et nous avons
une deux semaines comme nous l'a demandé
près dans la république pour préparer un
plan de déconfinement que nous
remettrons au premier ministre pour
préparer à partir du 11 mai le
déconfinement tous les secteurs et
notamment celui de la culture
vous pouvez compter sur moi et mes
équipes pour être mobilisés au service
de la culture et de toutes celles et
ceux qui travaillent merci monsieur le
ministre nous poursuivons notre séance
des questions portant sur des thèmes
divers toujours en lien avec la crise
sanitaire
la parole est à madame stéphanie risque
pour le groupe la république en marge
merci monsieur le président la question
de mon collègue bruno keitel s'adresse à
monsieur le ministre en charge des
collectivités locales il y associe les
députés allait re aiment élus locaux et
jean rené cazeneuve le président de la
délégation aux collectivités locales
hier soir le président de la république
s'est adressé aux françaises et aux
français pour apporter de nombreuses
réponses aux questions légitimes que nos
compatriotes se pose depuis la mise en
place du confinement dans son
intervention le président de la
république n'a pas manqué de souligner
le rôle essentiel des maires et des élus
locaux
depuis maintenant plusieurs semaines de
même il a souligné la mise en place de
nombreuses solidarité locale l'attention
aux plus fragiles et les multiples
capteurs que constituent les communes et
leurs élus quant au bon déroulement du
confinement d'une part et l'acceptation
de celui-ci par le plus grand nombre
d'autre part en annonçant la fin
prévisible du confinement à la date du
11 mai le président de la république a
également tracer une perspective pour le
plus grand nombre de nos compatriotes
dans ce cadre les municipalités seront
une nouvelle fois l'un des relais
essentiels pour chacun de nos
compatriotes
depuis l'adoption de la loi d'urgence
sanitaire et la publication de
ordonnance adapte et nous pouvons
affirmer que la démocratie locale est
préservée avec tous les moyens d'action
nécessaires pour agir en temps de crise
par ailleurs les services publics locaux
essentiels fonctionnent en cela nous
pouvons rendre hommage à nos élus et à
nos agents publics territoriaux en
première ligne une question importante
pour les municipales mais
municipalité mérite toutefois d'être
abordée on sait qu'à l'appel lisibilité
et perspectives en effet le 15 mars
dernier plus de 30 mille communes ont
élu leur municipalité dans leur totalité
ces nouvelles assemblées municipales
n'ont toujours pas pu être installé
il faudrait que des indications soient
délivrés sur ce point pouvez vous nous
en donner la visibilité
par ailleurs dans la perspective du
déconfinement et de la réouverture
progressive des établissements scolaires
pouvant pouvez vous nous préciser quel
sera le rôle des maires et des élus
locaux dans cette stratégie pour la
réussite duquel ces derniers seront
essentiels merci merci chers collègues
la parole monsieur sébastien lecornu
ministre chargé des collectivités
territoriales
merci monsieur le président mesdames
messieurs les députés madame la députée
vous l'avez rappelé le président la
république l'a fait hier soir un stand
orateurs ici l'ont fait précédemment le
rôle central des élus locaux des six
cent mille locaux et singulièrement des
mères de leurs adjoints et des
conseillers municipaux dans la gestion
de cette crise vous l'avez dit le
premier enjeu à relever était bien sûr
la continuité des services publics
locaux parfois comme coutume de le dire
le premier ministre ce n'est pas
spectaculaire mais la question de l'eau
la question des déchets la question de
l'assainissement sont autant de sujets
qu'il fallait garantir il ya plus d'un
mois nous avions des craintes sur ce
sujet le défi a été relevé sur
l'autorité du ministre de l'intérieur
est en lien avec les préfets bien sûr le
respect du confinement les maires sont
agents de l'état ont des pouvoirs de
police et évidemment la question des
doctrines d'emploi des polices
municipales coordonner avec les services
de sécurité intérieure donc là aussi un
rôle important qui a été qui était celui
des mères pendant la période de
confinement est encore donc pendant tout
un mois à venir
oui ils ont un rôle dans la période de
déconfinement son rôle sera à préciser
dans le cadre de la doctrine dont
parlait le premier ministre il ya
quelques instants et notamment jean
castex lui-même le délégué
interministériel et maire de sa commune
depuis de nombreuses années donc il sait
le rôle que les mères peuvent avoir sur
ce sujet nous en retour nous devions
nous devons deux choses aux élus locaux
la première des choses c'est permettre à
leurs collectivités territoriales de
fonctionner convenablement seul objet
des nombreuses ordonnances que nous
avons pris depuis maintenant trois
semaines par habilitation du parlement
bien évidemment qui permet aux
collectivités de fonctionner quasiment
normalement
en cette période de confinement la
démocratie locale de fait n'est pas en
panne et puis l'autre aspect sur lequel
évidemment nous sommes attendus
c'est l'installation des 30000 conseils
municipaux réputé complet au soir du
premier tour de l'élection municipale
dans la loi d'urgence le parlement à
préciser une date celle du 23 mai date à
laquelle le gouvernement de remettre un
rapport pour préciser justement les
conditions sanitaires si je vais vous le
dire en une phrase madame la députée le
gouvernement et le prémice rue l'indiqué
souhaite que l'installation de ces
conseils municipaux puissent se faire le
plus tôt possible dès que possible en
lien bien sûr avec les contraintes
sanitaires
merci monsieur le ministre la parole
était madame marie george buffet pour le
groupe de la gauche démocrate et
républicaine
merci monsieur le président nous vivons
une crise sanitaire douloureuse par le
nombre de pertes humaines angoissante
par ses conséquences sociales et
économiques
mais d'autres drames se déroule dans un
lieu clos celui où sont confinés des
familles celui hélas parfois des
violences intrafamiliales
comment s'enfuir comment téléphoner
quand l'auteur des violences est là en
permanence comment dire les poux comment
laisser voir les bleus dans l'école est
fermée
la vigilance est l'action de la nation
dans toutes ses composantes est plus que
jamais nécessaire des points des côtes
ont été ouverts dans des centres
commerciaux les pharmacies peuvent
désormais accueillir les femmes victimes
de violence afin de leur prêter
assistance et prévenir la police les
femmes et les enfants peuvent trouver de
l'aide aux 39 19 au 114 y compris par
sms ces mesures sont positives mais pas
encore assez connu aussi je propose peu
les messages officiels sur le coït 19
qui sont largement diffusés dans les
médias contiennent systématiquement une
information sur ces numéros d'urgence
face à ces drames
cela peut aider des voisins des
associations des élus à témoigner afin
que la police et la justice puisse agir
cela se fait en seine saint denis des
places d'hébergement et surtout des
logements peuvent être réservées partout
en france a fait d'accueillir en
sécurité les victimes cela demande un
accompagnement aussi toutes les
associations qui sont en permanence aux
côtés des femmes et des enfants doivent
recevoir en urgence de l'état les moyens
nécessaires au développement de leurs
actes
enfin je veux parler des enfants placés
est suivi par l'aide sociale à l'enfance
afin que nous puissions continuer à
protéger ses enfants
l'état doit permettre aux travailleurs
sociaux de pouvoir exercer le métier
dans les meilleures conditions
sanitaires possibles et ainsi assurer
aux départements les moyens pour assurer
l'accueil de ses enfants dans de bonnes
positions pendant le confinement
ce dont il s'agit ici c'est de notre
capacité à assurer l'intégrité physique
psychique et la dignité de nos
compatriotes les plus fragiles son
action publique et l'implication de
l'état rien ne sera comme avant
aussi monsieur le premier ministre
quelles sont les mesures que vous pouvez
mettre en oeuvre dans cette période
particulièrement difficile mais protéger
les chefs collègues la parole est à
madame sophie excusez-moi la parle d'un
monsieur christophe castaner ministre de
l'intérieur merci monsieur le président
mesdames messieurs débuté madame la
députée marie-george buffet vous avez
posé le cadre le cadre épouvantable de
cet enfermement qui peut provoquer de la
violence et une violence qui du coup est
subie parce qu'on ne peut pas appeler au
secours
c'est vrai pour des compagnes c'est vrai
pour des enfants et il est insupportable
d'imaginer que le confinement soit
synonyme d'impunité
vous avez évoqué quelques unes des
solutions que nous avons mises en place
par ce que nous avons souhaité que
justement nous savions la difficulté de
d'appeler police secours nous savions la
difficulté de pouvoir adresser ce
message d'urgence pour être protégés et
donc avec nicole belloubet avec marlene
shop avec adrien taquet nous avons
regardé que toutes les possibilités soit
ouverte pour pouvoir porter ce cri de
détresse
nous avons donné des instructions
extrêmement clair et en particulier je
les fais pour nos forces de sécurité
intérieure y compris pour faire des
appels d'initiative quand on connaît des
situations individuelles qui n'ont pas
donné lieu à des poursuites judiciaires
pour que dans l'entretien le policier de
gendarme puisse comprendre la situation
il ya évidemment ces outils absolument
nécessaire que nous avons renforcé je
pense à la plateforme arrêtons les
violences qui travaillent 24 heures par
jour et sept jours sur sept et nous
avons renforcé les moyens
je pense au suivi du 39 19 avec cet
accompagnement qui est porté là encore
des moyens renforcés
je pense à ces appels d'initiative je
pense au 17
évidemment mais vous avez évoqué les
pharmaciens les centres commerciaux et
si je prends le seul exemple des
pharmacies ce sont ces dernières
semaines et depuis la mise en place de
cet outil au moins quatre auteurs de
violence qui ont été interpellées à la
suite de signalements dans les
pharmacies et puis je pense aussi aux
sms vous l'avait annoncé il y a quelques
jours ici dans l'hémicycle 170 dossiers
sont accompagnés quotidiennement et il
nous faut des moyens notamment des
moyens d'hébergement et c'est la raison
pour laquelle marc lynch a pas évoqué la
mobilisation d'un million d'euros pour à
la fois accompagner les associations qui
jouent un rôle essentiel mais aussi
ouvrir la possibilité de vingt mille
nuitées supplémentaires et je finis en
vous disant que j'ai passé des messages
extrêmement clair au préfet pour qu en
aucun cas un problème matériel ne
s'oppose à la protection que nous devons
aux femmes et aux enfants
merci monsieur le ministre la parole est
à madame stéphanie rice pour le groupe
la république en marche
merci monsieur le président cette
question de ma collègue camille galliard
minier à laquelle elle associe notre
collègue emmanuel fontaine d'eau mais
elle s'adresse à madame sophie cluzel
secrétaire d'état auprès du premier
ministre chargé des personnes
handicapées
je suis devenu un robot j'enchaîne sans
réfléchir les tâches quotidiennes
je n'ai plus de temps pour moi je sens
que je peux craquer les larmes me
montent souvent aux yeux ces mots ce
sont ceux de servane hugues maman du
jeune antoine 14 ans polyhandicapé et
ils décrivent depuis le début du
confinement le quotidien de nombreuses
familles ayant à charge d'un enfant en
situation de handicap
la crise sanitaire sans précédent a
appelé le gouvernement à prendre des
dispositions inédite et parmi elles la
fermeture des centres d'accueil et des
établissements médico-sociaux décidée
pour des impératifs de sécurité
sanitaire ces fermetures ont eu pour
effet le retour des enfants en situation
de handicap au sein du domaine familial
loin d'être anodin ces retours ont
parfois été source de déséquilibre si le
gouvernement à décréter plusieurs
mesures en faveur de l'assouplissement
du confinement qui ont été salués elle
n'en demeure pas moins
insuffisante selon les familles les
initiatives associatives qu'il faut
saluer se sont multipliées tels que la
plateforme tous mobilisés de la
fédération grandir ensemble
madame la ministre après quatre semaines
de confinement la prolongation des
mesures inquiètent les familles compte
tenu de cette situation si particulière
pourriez-vous nous renseigner sur les
perspectives et calendrier de
réouverture des établissements
médico-sociaux envisagée par le
gouvernement
quelles solutions alternatives sont
envisagées afin de soulager la détresse
des personnes en situation de handicap
et de leurs proches je vous remercie
merci chers collègues la parole au terme
dames sophie cluzel se tait hautes
herbes et a chargé des personnes
handicapées
merci monsieur le président merci madame
la députée de vous faire le porte-voix
de mesdames gaillard min et fontaine de
moselle que je salue
j'ai eu l'occasion de partager avec
servane hugues la maman d'antoine sur sa
situation
comme avec beaucoup d'autres familles et
les écoutant je sais à quel point les
contraintes qui ont été posés pour
protéger la santé de nos concitoyens
contraintes inédite mais nécessaires
peuvent être difficiles à vivre au
quotidien
je connais aussi l'engagement de loisirs
pluriel est celui de tous les
professionnels et les bénévoles auprès
des familles pendant cette crise et
notamment à domicile et je les remercie
avec la prolongation du confinement nous
avons ajusté début avril le cadre des
réponses pour soutenir et éviter
l'épuisement des aidants dans le
contexte de la fermeture des externats
que vous vous avez rappelé les
professionnels du médico social se sont
mobilisés pour accompagner à domicile
ces familles avec enfants et adultes
nous avons identifié des solutions de
répit quand les situations ne tiennent
plus cela peut être dur des ja ja
domicile la mobilisation d'un crédit
d'heures auprès des caf l'organisation
de sorties cas individualisés avec un
professionnel dans les espaces verts des
établissements cela peut être aussi si
besoin l'accueil temporaire de l'aider
en interne à sept jours voire même 14
jours la plate forme solidaire handicap
à l'initiative du cncph de l'encré à y
recense des solutions de proximité pour
qui peuvent faciliter la vie des
familles de même nous avons assoupli
avec christophe castaner les règles de
sortie pour les personnes pour
lesquelles le confinement strict conduit
à augmenter les troubles de comportement
ou altérer la santé mentale
nous travaillons à la mise en oeuvre au
plus près des familles de ces
possibilités en équité sur les
territoires et je sais la mobilisation
des parlementaires à ce sujet je serai
demain matin encore avec eux pour
partager justement les innovations et
faire redescendre toutes les mesures qui
ont été mises en place nous sommes aussi
à la tâche dans le cadre que le
président de la république fixée hier en
lien avec les associations les
administrations pour définir les
modalités d'accompagnement de la
réouverture progressive des externats
après le 11 mai et les perspectives
propres de ce noeud de nos concitoyens
handicapés dont la santé est la plus
fragile et à préserver
merci merci madame la ministre stéphanie
risque pour le groupe la république en
marche merci messieurs président ma
question s'adresse à monsieur jean yves
le drian ministre de l'europe et des
affaires étrangères
dans ce contexte de crise sanitaire
notre solidarité avec nos pays voisins
européens est entière et nous savons
compter sur leur soutien et appui
illustré aujourd'hui par la prise en
charge de dizaines de patients français
en particulier par l'allemagne
l'autriche la suisse et le luxembourg
cet élan d'entr'aide a déjà sauvé des
vies et montre une fois de plus la
nécessité de penser et d'agir européens
en particulier dans les moments de
tension comme ceux que nous connaissons
actuellement
certains estiment que l'allemagne ferait
preuve de plus de résilience car elle
déplore à ce jour moins de décès
pourtant la comparaison entre la france
et l'allemagne n'est pas aisé voire
trompeuse puisque de nombreuses données
sont à prendre en compte
différences culturelles ou
démographiques organisation du système
de santé ou encore stade de l'épidémie
auxquels le pays se trompe tout ceci
doit nous inciter à la prudence nous
manquons de recul pour tirer
d'éventuelles conclusions sur la gestion
de crise pour autant des comparaisons
parfois hâtives fleurissent et certains
citoyens s'interroge dès lors au stade
actuel comment expliquer ces approches
parfois différentes entre nos deux pays
yat-il certaines actions mises en oeuvre
pour nos amis allemands qui pourrait
nous inspirer dans la lutte contre ce
fléau
la question peut aussi se poser du point
de vue de l'accompagnement économique
l'allemagne a mis en place un plan de
soutien massif à destination des
entreprises en difficulté de leurs
salariés
la stratégie économique de la france est
elle différente
cette épidémie exigent davantage de
coopération entre nos deux pays
comment comptez vous renforcer encore
la coopération sanitaire et économique
franco allemande afin de donner
davantage de cohérence et d'efficacité
aux mesures nationales enfin dans le
cadre de la réflexion sur les
perspectives de déconfinement
actuellement en cours
est il prévu une coordination des
actions à l'échelle européenne
je vous remercie merci chers collègues
la porte à monsieur jean yves le drian
ministre de l'europe et des affaires
étrangères oui madame la députée
stéphanie rist vous l'avez dit la
coopération européenne est clé pour
vaincre le virus et dans ce cadre la
coopération franco allemande joue un
rôle moteur comme sur beaucoup de sujets
elle le joue d'abord au niveau de la
solidarité
pratique pragmatique comme vous l'avez
souligné par l'accueil de plusieurs
dizaines de patients français du grand
est en réanimation dans les
établissements allemands comme aussi eu
le rapatriement en commun de plusieurs
centaine de nos ressortissants de
passage coincés à l'étranger
cette coopération elle agit aussi en
termes de gestion de nos frontières
frontière extérieure mais aussi
frontières intérieures nous avons tout
fait pour que les mesures prises aux
frontières et le moins d'impact possible
sur les travailleurs transfrontaliers
sur la circulation des marchandises et
sur le maintien de leur emploi et leur
situation budgétaire et fiscale et je
voudrais profiter de votre question
madame la députée pour saluer la
condamnation fait par mon homologue pays
comme à ceux récemment de certains
comportement détestable à l'encontre de
nos compatriotes transfrontalier cette
coopération franco-allemande énergie
aussi dans le domaine économique il est
clair que la coopération entre la france
et l'allemagne par le biais de bruno le
maire et de rôle action a été
déterminante
la semaine dernière pour l'aboutissement
dans le cadre de l'eurogroupe un paquet
d'investissements de 500 milliards
d'euros
et aussi à l'engagement commun de mettre
en oeuvre un fonds de relance
elle existe aussi dans le domaine
sanitaire
que à la fois jan valtin olivier véran
se rencontrent régulièrement ils
changent régulièrement sur la
coordination des enjeux sanitaires même
si vous savez l'avait dit les
comparaisons ne sont pas faciles et puis
les hissent aussi au niveau
international puisque jeudi prochain
heiko maas mon collègue allemand et moi
même nous allons prendre l'initiative de
réunir l'alliance pour le
multilatéralisme pour préparer le monde
d'après pour la coopération
internationale dans ce domaine et c'est
une initiative très fort liée aussi aux
difficultés que rencontre l'organisation
mondiale de la santé pour faire valoir
le nouveau multilatéralisme dans le
domaine de la santé
merci monsieur le ministre la parole est
à monsieur fuchs pour monsieur
bourlanges groix du groupe vous ment
démocrate et apparence est exact c'est
une question de jean louis bourlanges
qui s'adressa à jean yves le drian sa
qualité de ministre des affaires
européennes au mieux les épreuves
actuelles nous sommes heureux de voir
que grâce en particulier à l'action de
la france les européens ont jusqu'à
présent fait face à l'urgence
les états membres ont su sans délai
s'affranchir pragmatiquement des
contraintes budgétaires que la récession
en cours
rand est contre-productive la banque
centrale a pris quant à elles toutes ses
responsabilités pour permettre à chacun
de financer à des taux raisonnables les
énormes besoins créés par la situation
bien plus l'union a pris de l'avancé en
s'attachant à réfléchir dès maintenant
aux exigences du jour d'après je vise en
particulier la volonté de fonder sur de
nouvelles bases
l'action du mécanisme européen de
stabilité et celle de mettre en place un
fonds de reconstruction de nos économies
je pense aussi à la nécessité de faire
franchir un budget de l'union
un double saut qualitatif et quantitatif
le groupe modem tiens à vous dire sa
fierté de voir la france
être au premier rang de ce grand combat
pour un supplément d'europe
cette relance de l'action européenne
n'en portera toutefois l'adhésion qu'à
la condition de ne plus être perçu comme
un éternel efforts de correction des
défaillances antérieures
il faut devenir un vecteur
une véritable innovation collective
ambitieuse et solidaire ni le mécanisme
européen de stabilité d'hier ni les
eurobonds version canal historique ne
peuvent être un modèle pour demain pour
fonder sur des bases solides une
stratégie commune de réparation
économique et social ne pensez vous pas
monsieur le ministre qu'il est devenu
inévitable de clarifier le pacte de
subsidiarité et de solidarité qui nous
unit dire que chacun doit faire seul et
faire avec les autres est devenue un
impératif catégorique
en ces temps de tragédie la france
at-elle pas le devoir pour parler comme
malraux d'aider l'europe à prendre
conscience de la grandeur qu'elle ignore
en elle merci chers collègues la parole
était monsieur jean yves le drian
ministre de l'europe et des affaires
étrangères oui monsieur le monsieur le
député jean-louis bourlanges a raison
l'europe est au rendez vous il ya eu un
petit peu de mal au démarrage mais elle
est vraiment au rendez vous parce que
jamais il n'y a eu une telle
mobilisation de tous les instruments
disponibles de tous les outils
disponibles et à un niveau jamais
atteint
vous les avez cité que soit la banque
centrale européenne que ce soit la
banque européenne d'investissement que
ce soit le mécanisme européen de
stabilité oui l'europe est au
rendez-vous et au delà de ces outils la
réponse européenne et elle est même au
delà de ce que certains considéraient
jusqu'à il ya peu de temps comme un
possible voire même irresponsable je
pense à l'assouplissement considérable
des règles en matière d'aidés d'état et
des règles du pacte de stabilité et de
croissance ou fameux 3%
l'europe a su s'affranchir en cette
période dramatique des tabous et des
dogues
mais vous avez raison jean louis
bourlanges a raison cela ne suffit pas
il faut aller beaucoup plus loin et en
ap le vent de vaud veut une
clarification de ce que vous nommez le
pack de subsidiarité et de solidarité
vous posez la question majeure
l'europe est elle capable de se
réinventer où est-elle seulement voyez à
réagir aux événements qu'elle subit est
en avance et que lorsqu'elle est
confrontée à une crise comme on a
souvent coutume de le dire
et notre réponse est claire la crise que
nous vivons
je le dis parce que j'en suis intimement
convaincu doit être pour l'union un
accélérateur de refondation un
accélérateur de refondation pour que à
la sortie de cette crise cette
refondation permettent à l'europe d'être
à la fois plus solidaire plus
pragmatique plus réactive mais aussi
plus souveraine et surtout qu'elle soit
consciente puisque vous citez malraux de
sa puissance qui doit s'imposer et
dentelles doit être elle même très fier
alors dans ce cadre là le grand test de
demain ce sera effectivement la mise en
oeuvre du fonds de relance qui avait
déjà été initié par la réunion de
l'eurogroupe j'espère que lors de la
réunion des prêts des conseils européens
la parole stephanie rice dont le groupe
la république en marche une question
monsieur krabal merci monsieur le
président la question de mon collègue
jacques krabal s'adresse au ministre de
l'europe et des affaires étrangères la
france continuent de mener la guerre
contre les copies de 19 sur le
territoire national dans les dom-tom
médecins infirmières infirmiers et
agents de service dans les hôpitaux les
ehpad à domicile qu'on bat avec courage
partout les forces de sécurité veillent
au respect du confinement pour la santé
de tous la france est debout grâce aussi
à celles et ceux de la deuxième ligne
agriculteur éboueurs facteurs
enseignants caissière élu je n'oublie
pas les clubs services bénévoles et
chefs d'entreprise comme à montreuil aux
lions
il confectionne des protections pour les
soignants des hôpitaux de
château-thierry de villiers saint denis
du sud de l'aisne et bien au delà
vous le constatez la ruralité est aussi
au rendez vous la france tout comme
l'europe va vaincre cette épidémie mais
cette pandémie ème mondiale si elle se
développe en afrique et dans les pays en
voie de développement nous resterons
menacer la fragilité
hors système de santé les rend encore
plus vulnérables
le respect des gestes barrière est
difficile comment se laver les mains
quand il n'y a pas d'eau comment rester
confinés dans un espace restreint ou
quand la fin vous tenaille le directeur
de l' oms prévient qu'il faut se
préparer au pire
l'assemblée parlementaire de la
francophonie tire aussi le signal
d'alarmé
certes l'union européenne a débloqué une
aide de 15 milliards d'euros en faveur
des pays vulnérables
quelle réforme la france va-t-elle
déployés pour inciter les instances
internationales le fmi la banque
mondiale à aider davantage les pays
africains quelle est la position de la
france sur la demande d'allègement de la
dette africaine
merci de votre réponse nationale merci
chers collègues la part de monsieur jean
yves le drian ministre de l'europe et
des affaires étrangères je réponds
volontiers à la question du député
jacques krabal dont je sait
l'attachement aux enjeux du continent
africain et je voudrais lui dire que en
afrique
nous regardons la situation sans
catastrophisme sans prédictions
alarmistes mais néanmoins avec une
extrême vigilance parce que la vague du
coc vite 19 monte après avoir atteint
plus tardivement l'afrique parce que les
systèmes de santé africains sont
fragiles et parce que les mesures de
confinement prise de façon courageuse
par plusieurs pays risquent d'impacter
durablement les habitants qui souvent
vivent au jour le jour donc nous devons
aider l'afrique dans cette période
devons le faire par solidarité avec des
pays amis je voudrais d'ailleurs dire
ici que ce lien humain entre l'afrique
et la france est tragiquement illustré
par ce médecin urgentiste
franco-malgache formés en france qui
était revenue prêter main forte à
compiègne et qui restera comme la
première victime en france victimes au
front du coc vite 19 aider l'afrique
aujourd'hui c'est aussi répondre aux
intérêts de la france en agissant dans
notre voisinage pour écarter la menace
d'un effet de retour d'un effet
boomerang d'une deuxième vague qui
viendrait nous frapper demain
alors que nous serions en phase de
récupération et pour cela le présent de
la république développe avec ses
partenaires européens une stratégie ou
autour du soutien au système de santé
africains nous allons réorienter pour
cela notre aide au développement
bilatéral réorienter à hauteur de 1
milliard 200 millions d'euros en dons
est on prêt sur des crédits qu'ils
étaient destinés à d'autres actions de
développement nous le faisons aussi dans
un cadre multilatéral avec la
mobilisation du fonds mondial de lutte
contre le sida avec des mobilisations du
gavi d'unitaid
tous les fonds ou bell nous participons
nous voulons aussi le soutenir
grâce à l'expertisé scientifique
africaine pour trouver des solutions
ensemble et le faire aussi par le
soutien à l'activité économique vous
avez pu entendre hier le président de la
république souhaitait un moratoire et
des anus et des annulations massives de
dettes qui seront des actes majeurs pour
la coopération avec l'afrique dans cette
période merci monsieur le ministre la
séance des questions au gouvernement est
terminée je vous remercie de sortir de
manière échelonnée prochaine séance
vendredi 17 avril à 9h projet de loi de
finances rectificative pour 2020 la
séance est levée